Hey guys, good morning. I'm drinking some tea. What do you got? Uh, spit? Spit in my mouth? That's about it. Welcome to Smartless. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Hey, what do you got, do you call it a toiletry bag or do you call it a dop, is it dop kit, D-O-P?
嘿，大家早。我在喝茶。你们有什么？呃，口水？吐到我嘴里？差不多就这些。欢迎收听 Smartless。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。Smart。Lattice。嘿，你们怎么叫那个洗漱包，叫 dop 吗，是叫 dop 包，D-O-P 吗？
D-O-P is in fall? We went through this on stage in front of thousands of people. Oh, I don't remember things. Wait, but what is? Do you not remember? No. We were on tour, we were in Washington, D.C., it was our first night.
D-O-P 是指秋天？我们在舞台上当着几千人的面讨论过这个。噢，我不记事。等等，那是什么？你不记得了？没有。我们在巡回演出，在华盛顿特区，那是我们的第一晚。
Yeah, and we got Sam Jones as a gift, right? Didn't we? I don't remember that part. I don't remember gifting him anything. Oh, look who's memory's a little soft. No. No. No.
对，我们还收到了山姆·琼斯送的礼物，对吧？难道不是吗？我不记得那部分了。我不记得送过他什么礼物。哦，瞧瞧谁的记性有点模糊了。不。不。不。
No. But what does Dopp-Kit mean, D-O-P? It's German, right, for toiletry stuff. It's German, man. Remember, somebody in the audience yelled it out and they said it's German. I forget how it came about. Anyways, yes, D-O-P-P, Dopp-Kit. Hey, why, go ahead. Go ahead. and they said, I forget how it came about.
没有。但 Dopp-Kit 是什么意思，D-O-P？是德语，对吧，指洗漱用品。是德语，老兄。记得当时观众席里有人大喊，说那是德语。我忘了是怎么来的了。总之，对，D-O-P-P，Dopp 包。嘿，为什么，你请。请便。他们说，我忘了是怎么来的了。
Anyways, yes, DOPP, Dopp kit. I can't sleep. Guys, real quick, the word was coined by leather worker Charles Doppelt who patented the idea of Dopp's in 1919 and marketed them locally before landing a contract with the US Army during WWII. And that he was a German? Leatherworker, I think he was American. Let's see. Well, it sounds German.
总之，是的，DOPP，Dopp 包。我睡不着。伙计们，简单说一下，这个词是由皮革工匠查尔斯·多普elt（Charles Doppelt）创造的，他在 1919 年为 Dopp 专利申请了专利，并在当地进行销售，后来在二战期间赢得了美国陆军的合同。他是个德国人？皮革工匠，我想他是美国人。让我们看看。嗯，听起来像德语。
More to come next episode. Trust Doppel, D-O-P-P-E-L-T, yeah, yeah, yeah. Now I'm looking at it too. I also have the internet, Bennett. So. Congrats, guys. It's like when we get back, you know when we brought this up before, people go, I did my own research,
下集更精彩。相信 Doppel，D-O-P-P-E-L-T，对，对，对。现在我也在看。我也有网络，班奈特。所以。恭喜你们，伙计们。就像我们回来的时候，你知道我们以前提起这个的时候，人们会说，我自己做过研究，
like oh you've got Google, fuck off. Yeah, exactly. Takes like five seconds. So last night. Oh sorry Sean, we were trying to get to some business. Sean's like, yeah I know, takes five seconds. So my story that I've got ready. No, I was actually serious about like that,
就像，哦，你有谷歌，滚开。对，完全正确。只要五秒钟。所以昨晚。哦，抱歉，肖恩，我们正想谈正事。肖恩就像，是的，我知道，只要五秒钟。所以这是我准备好的故事。不，我其实挺认真的，
I can't stop clearing my throat. I don't know why. Does that mean I'm getting sick? I don't know. Or do you want to reschedule today's recording? No, no. It might be the smoke from the Canadian fires. I think that's the Toronto Maple Leafs fans still
我一直忍不住清嗓子。我不知道为什么。这代表我要生病了吗？我不知道。还是你想改期今天的录音？不，不。可能是加拿大山火的烟雾吧。我觉得那是多伦多枫叶队的球迷还在
being a handful up there. What happened? Did they win? Dude, dude, we don't need to get the fucking shots fired over there. Are they not doing well? It's, they've, that's an understatement. It's been a minute. It's been a tough, I haven't mentioned it since. It's been a while but they lost again in another game seven and it was really good. Boy, that, that, I can't believe it seven and it was really good to take that off.
那边大惊小怪。发生什么事了？他们赢了吗？老兄，老兄，我们不需要在那里开火。他们表现得不好吗？这是，他们已经，这话说得太保守了。好久不见了。这很艰难，我从那以后就没提过了。已经有一段时间了，但他们在另一场抢七大战中又输了，而且打得很好。天哪，那，那，真不敢相信七场，把那个拿掉真好。
I can't believe it, I still haven't talked to you about it. I watched all three periods of you and Biz doing your commentary on that game with your blazers on. I can't, I mean I sat there, I had the clicker in my hand the whole time, never punched it, just watched you two I want to see it. Flather on.
真不敢相信，我到现在还没跟你聊过这事。我看了你和比斯穿着西装外套对那场比赛进行评论的所有三节比赛。我真的，我的意思是我就坐在那，手里一直拿着遥控器，从来没按过，就看着你们两个。我想看。喋喋不休。
I didn't see it. You know what the best part was, and I took a shot at you because I said, Baby was supposed to be here, he's like literally a mile away. I was less than a mile away, still just smiling at you saying, yeah, you know, he might even stop by during this.
我没看。你知道最棒的部分是什么吗，我还嘲笑你，因为我说，贝比本该在这里的，他简直就在一英里外。我离不到一英里，还冲你笑着说，对，你知道，他甚至可能会在这期间顺便过来。
And I was just like laughing at myself. That's not going to happen. DJs. But you know, the best part was, they go, do you guys want to go do this? And Biz and I were like, yeah, let's do it. And we get there, we do the pregame, and then we go to this other studio
然后我只是自己在那笑。那是不可能的。DJ。但你知道最棒的部分是什么吗，他们问，你们想去搞这个吗？然后比斯和我当时就说，好，我们去吧。我们到了那里，做了赛前准备，然后我们去了另一个工作室
to start this kind of alt-cast thing. And then just the dude goes, in five, four, three. And I'm like, hey everybody, we had no plan, you can tell. Oh really? And then we had like, luckily. And you just commented on this game? Yeah, we just talked. They're just literally watching the game
来开始这种所谓的另类直播。然后那家伙就说，五，四，三。我就说，大家好，我们没有计划，你们看得出来。哦，真的吗？然后我们有，幸好。你就在这场比赛里做解说？对，我们只是聊天。他们就真的是在边看比赛
along with the audience at home. That's fun. And doing their own commentary. And we just commented on this game. Yeah, we just talked. Literally watching the game along with the audience at home. That's fun. And doing their own commentary. We had Charles Barkley kindly called in. He was amazing. He was great, yeah. He was hilarious. And then our buddy Al Michaels.
边和家里的观众互动。挺有意思的。做他们自己的评论。我们刚刚评论了这场比赛。对，我们只是在聊天。简直就是和家里的观众一起看比赛。真有意思。做他们自己的评论。查尔斯·巴克利好心地打电话进来了。他太棒了。他太棒了，对。他太逗了。然后还有我们的好朋友阿尔·迈克尔斯。
Yeah, also amazing. Also amazing. Sorry, Sean, do you think Charles Barkley's a singer? I always think he's the singer, right? Isn't there a singer named Charles Barkley? Narles Barkley. Do you think it might have gone the other way? Oh, Narles Barkley. Yeah, you think maybe Nar have gone the other way? Oh, Narls Barkley.
对，也很棒。也很棒。抱歉，肖恩，你觉得查尔斯·巴克利是个歌手吗？我一直觉得他是那个歌手，对吧？不是有个歌手叫查尔斯·巴克利吗？纳尔斯·巴克利（Gnarls Barkley）。你觉得会不会是反过来的？哦，纳尔斯·巴克利。对，你觉得纳尔也许反过来了？哦，纳尔斯·巴克利。
You think maybe Narls got it from Charles. Do you think Arnold Palmer the golfer gave himself the name after the drink? Sweet Sean. Hey, by the way, Sean, think about how sweet Sean is. Franny, my eldest listener, she had a scavenger hunt last night and I guess one of the boxes they had to check
你觉得会不会是纳尔从查尔斯那借来的？你觉得高尔夫球手阿诺德·帕尔默（Arnold Palmer）是根据那款饮料给自己起的名字吗？甜蜜的肖恩。嘿，顺便说一句，肖恩，想想肖恩有多甜。弗兰妮，我年纪最大的听众，她昨晚有个寻宝游戏，我猜其中一个他们需要勾选的任务
was get a picture with a celebrity. And Sean was nice enough to stay up until- Introduce them to some celebrities? That'd be so nice. Right this way. 1030, 1045 or something, she drove over to your house with all of her friends and took a shot of you? Yeah, I'm like, what's going on with your dad?
就是和名人合影。然后肖恩人很好，一直呆到——把他们引见给一些名人？那太好了。这边请。10点30分，10点45分左右，她和她所有的朋友开车到你家，给你拍了张照？对，我在想，你爸怎么了？
Can't you just take a shot with him? I guess I don't count. I guess you didn't count because of that. Now, did you go through the works before they got over there? Were you, was your hair and your makeup was all set? Check out that photo. It's horrible.
难道你不能直接跟他合张影吗？我猜我不算数。我猜你因为那个就不算数了。那么，在他们到那儿之前，你打扮好了吗？你的头发和妆都弄好了吗？看看那张照片。太可怕了。
I look like I'm 95 years old. Oh, so you checked it. You said, let me see it. Yeah, well, I did it myself. Because you know, when somebody stops and asks for a photo, which is so kind, I always grab the phone. I said, let me take it because it takes me two seconds
我看起来像95岁老头。哦，所以你检查过了。你说，让我看看。好吧，我自己拍的。因为你知道，当有人停下来要求合影时，这太好了，我总是抢过手机。我说，让我来拍，因为我花两秒钟
to open the phone. Otherwise, it takes half an hour for them to wait. I got to find my phone icons. I said, let me take it because it takes me two seconds to open the phone, otherwise it takes half an hour for them. Wait, I gotta find my phone icon. I'm like, just give it to me. And so I took it with all them, because it's a scavenger hunt, so you only have five seconds. So I said, everybody stand behind.
就能打开手机。不然他们得等上半小时。我得找我的手机图标。我说，让我来拍，因为我花两秒钟就能打开手机，不然他们得等上半小时。等等，我得找找我的手机图标。我就想，直接给我吧。所以我跟他们所有人都拍了，因为这是个寻宝游戏，所以你只有五秒钟时间。所以我说，大家都站到后面去。
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I don't know that rule. What are you talking about? Well, it's a scavenger hunt. You gotta get your thing and you gotta go. Oh, oh, gotcha, okay. The thing and the list and then go. So, but I had to hang out with them for like five, 10 minutes because their friends were in another car.
哇，哇，哇，我不知道这个规则。你在说什么呢？好吧，这是个寻宝游戏。你得拿到你的东西然后赶紧走。哦，哦，明白了，好吧。东西和清单，然后走。所以，但我不得不跟他们闲晃了大约五、十分钟，因为他们的朋友在另一辆车里。
Anyway, who cares? And I took a photo of myself and it didn't look great. But Franny's the sweetest. I hope this is gonna be in your book. I mean, that's riveting. You know, you're telling me that story about grabbing everybody's phone and taking the picture of yourself all the time.
不管怎样，谁在乎呢？我给自己拍了张照，看起来不太好。但弗兰妮最贴心了。我希望这会写进你的书里。我的意思是，这太引人入胜了。你知道的，你跟我讲那个总是抢别人的手机给自己拍照的故事。
And I immediately go to all the germs that I would be taking on my hands by touching everybody else's phone. You know it's the dirtiest thing in your life? Your iPhone? Well, I think your mouth is. No, it's dirtier than your toilet seat. Again, I just want to point out,
我脑子里立刻浮现出，通过触摸别人的手机，我的手上会沾上多少细菌。你知道这是你生活中最脏的东西吗？你的iPhone？嗯，我觉得你的嘴才是。不，它比你的马桶座还要脏。再次重申，我只是想指出，
are you watching people drop dead on the street or something? Because we're all fine. No, it's just a gross factor. I'm not worried about getting sick. I did though, but I did want, Franny texted me earlier in the day. She's like, are you going to be up like about between 10th and 11th?
你是在看人们倒在街上死掉还是怎么的？因为我们都好好的。不，这只是恶心程度的问题。我不担心生病。不过我确实，弗兰妮当天早些时候给我发了短信。她说，你10点到11点左右会醒着吗？
I'm like, yeah. And then, and I'm watching the Osama Bin Laden documentary and I'm completely falling asleep. As you do. It was really interesting. So good. And I, yeah, it's amazing. Oh really?
我说，对。然后，我正在看本·拉登的纪录片，然后我完全睡着了。正如你所做的那样。真的很有趣。太棒了。我，是的，太棒了。哦，真的吗？
And it's so interesting. And then I'm just falling asleep on the couch in McSky, I go to sleep, I'm going to fall asleep. And she's like, we're here. I was like, oh God, and the doorbell rang. I freaked out and I went outside. And then my phone goes up at like one in the morning. And she's like, are you still up?
太有意思了。然后我就在麦斯基的沙发上睡着了，我去睡觉了，我要睡着了。然后她说，我们到了。我当时想，天哪，门铃响了。我吓坏了，出去了。然后差不多凌晨一点，我的电话响了。她说，你还没睡吗？
Because I think they needed something else. I needed to be. Yeah. Oh no. And then I just text her. That's like the worst are you Still Up text you can get. From Franny. You know what I mean?
因为我想他们还需要点别的。我需要成为。噢，不。然后我给她发短信。那简直是你能收到的最糟糕的“你还没睡吗”短信。来自弗兰妮。你知道我的意思吗？
On the scales of R U Still Up text. It's not what you think. Yeah, it's not what you think. Can we get a photo with you? Yeah, exactly. Maybe the photo was bad, but I was freaking out. I hope she won. Do you know if she won?
在“你还没睡吗”短信的衡量标准上。这不是你想的那样。对，不是你想的那样。我们能跟你合个影吗？对，完全正确。也许照片拍得不好，但我当时吓坏了。我希望她赢了。你知道她赢了吗？
I have no idea. She hasn't surfaced yet. It's 940 this morning. Well, she went to bed at like three in the morning. We should do a smartless scavenger hunt. I would love that. I love a scavenger hunt. I do too. That would be super fun. Yeah.
我完全不知道。她还没露面呢。今天早上9点40。好吧，她差不多凌晨三点才睡。我们应该搞个智能寻宝游戏。我太喜欢了。我喜欢寻宝游戏。我也喜欢。那超级有趣。对。
So how would that work? The three of us would be individually against one another? No, no, no. It's not for us. It's for our fans. It's for, you know, for people who like listen to podcasts and then we have like a whole, yeah. God, that sounds like a lot of work. What's the prize? You're so angry about it.
那怎么个玩法？我们三个分别互相对抗吗？不，不，不。这不是给我们准备的。这是给我们粉丝的。这是给，你知道的，给那些喜欢听播客的人准备的，然后我们有整个，对。天哪，听起来好多工作。奖品是什么？你对此好生气啊。
A Dopp kit. A Dopp kit. Oh, a smart Dopp kit. Nice. It's a Dopp kit. And because you wrapped it up with such a nice bow, Willie, we're going to move on to our guest today. Beautiful.
一个 Dopp 包。一个 Dopp 包。哦，一个智能 Dopp 包。不错。是个 Dopp 包。因为你用这么漂亮的蝴蝶结把它包好了，威利，我们要进入今天的嘉宾环节了。太棒了。
Oh, nice. Who's this? Is it yours today, Seanny? Yes, yes. That's a delicious segue. Oh, you guys are going to love this, it's so exciting. He got his first big break by tagging along to a friend's audition and improvising his way
哦，不错。这是谁？今天是你的吗，肖恩？是的，是的。这是一个美妙的过渡。哦，你们会爱死这个的，太令人兴奋了。他通过陪朋友去试镜并在试镜时即兴发挥
into the role, it was a big movie. He has such a thick Liverpool accent that fans don't often believe it's real. He used to tear up the streets as a teenage break dancer, so did I, and he's been punched, stabbed, and screamed at in more scenes than I can count, but somehow he's the most gentle guy in the room. I met him once on his native soil, the UK,
得到了自己的第一个重大突破角色，那是一部大片。他有着非常浓重的利物浦口音，以至于粉丝们经常不相信那是真的。他曾经是个十几岁时在街上大跳霹雳舞的舞者，我也是，而且他在比我能数得清的更多的场景中被殴打、刺伤和怒吼过，但不知为何他却是房间里最温柔的人。我曾在他的故土英国见过他一次，
and I've been a fan ever since. It's the ridiculously talented and allegedly intimidating Stephen Graham. Hey, Stephen Graham! Woo! Hello! Hello, gentlemen. Good morning.
从那以后我就一直是他的粉丝。他就是才华横溢、据说很有压迫感的斯蒂芬·格雷姆。嘿，斯蒂芬·格雷姆！呜！你好！你好，各位先生。早安。
Look at that sweet face who would beat the shit out of me. That was a world-class reveal. It was just so dramatic. It was great. And oftentimes, they're very much. Thank you. That was very good. Now, Will, do you want to get started
看看那张甜美的脸，谁会把我往死里打。那真是一个世界级的亮相。太戏剧化了。太棒了。而且通常情况下，他们非常。谢谢。那非常好。好了，威利，你想开始
on the Liverpool football club conversation and get it out of the way? No, we're going to end on that. We're going to end on the glory on Liverpool. OK. I'm a massive supporter, Steven, a massive supporter, so we'll get to it. Nice, great. Can I jump in on the scavenger hunting?
聊利物浦足球俱乐部的谈话并把它先解决掉吗？不，我们要以这个结尾。我们要以利物浦的荣耀结尾。好的。我是个铁杆球迷，斯蒂芬，一个铁杆球迷，所以我们会聊到的。太好了，棒极了。我能插话聊聊寻宝游戏吗？
Please, go nuts. I was at a mate's, because we were in LA for a little bit. I heard about this, because my wife was there at Guy's house, right? Yes. Guy Ritchie? Close. Well, let him tell the time.
请便，随便说。我在一个朋友家，因为我们在洛杉矶待了一会儿。我听说过这个，因为我妻子在盖伊家，对吧？是的。盖伊·里奇？接近了。好吧，让他讲讲时间。
Oh, wow. Go ahead. Yeah, yeah, yeah, the time. Oh wow. Go ahead. Yeah, yeah, yeah, my wife is Amanda. Amanda was there. She was probably the one that made your ears bleed just a little bit when you were wondering, why am I here? No, she was talking quietly in the corner
哦，哇。请讲。对，对，对，时间。哦，哇。请讲。对，对，对，我妻子是阿曼达。阿曼达在那。她可能就是那个让你耳朵流了一点血的人，当时你在想，我为什么会在这里？不，她当时在角落里安静地跟某人说话，
with somebody holding their arm. Oh yeah, or it was her. No, I did, yeah, she was lovely. What's the story, Steven? What happened? It was just, during the day, a friend, we went to his sister, she graduated. Correct.
挽着他们的胳膊。哦，对，或者就是她。不，我确实，是的，她很可爱。什么故事，斯蒂芬？发生什么了？那只是，在白天，一个朋友，我们去了他姐姐家，她毕业了。没错。
And she was telling us about her scavenger hunt that she was going on. And I'll tell you what, there was a bit risky some of the stuff that they get really high points for. Oh really, like what? Yeah, like I mean, eating a bagel off a man's penis. No way.
她跟我们讲了她正在进行的寻宝游戏。我告诉你，有些东西拿高分还挺冒险的。哦，真的吗，比如什么？对，比如，从一个男人的阴茎上吃百吉饼。没门。
Not risking it. That's Jason. Isn't that true? Jason, did you win that? Did you win that one, Jason? Well, you know, you need to get a unit that'll actually fit inside that hole. And so... I just had that for breakfast today. Wait, Jason, Amanda was doing this? What's happening? It was a little bit more of a bi-ali for me, but...
不冒这个险。那是杰森。难道不是真的吗？杰森，你赢了那个吗？你赢了那个吗，杰森？嗯，你知道的，你需要找一个真正能塞进那个洞里的尺寸。所以……我今天早上刚吃了那个。等等，杰森，阿曼达在做这个？怎么回事？对我来说这算是不在场证明，但是……
Wait, that's crazy. Is that real, like crazy shit like that? Well, here at this party, right, Stephen, this was also get a picture with a celebrity, and at your party, there were some real celebrities there. Sean, I'll do respect. Sure, now I get it. We're talking about the tops in the business,
等等，太疯狂了。真的有这种疯狂的事情吗？好吧，在这个派对上，对吧，斯蒂芬，这也是要和名人合影，而在你的派对上，那里有一些真正的名人在。肖恩，恕我直言。当然，现在我明白了。我们谈论的是业内顶尖人物，
like Steven, and there was a whole group photo, so they got major points, I'm assuming. Yeah, because we went outside and took a photo. Yeah, but it was just when they were explaining to us in the morning what kind of things actually happen and how many points you get for certain things, it just got rather disgusting, I thought. Yeah, really?
比如斯蒂芬，还有一个全体大合影，所以我猜他们拿了高分。对，因为我们走到外面拍了张照。对，但这只是当他们在早上向我们解释到底会发生什么样的事情以及某些事情能得多少分时，我觉得这变得相当令人作呕。真的吗？
My elder said to me when he was doing his a couple weeks ago, he said, hey, can I get my nose pierced because I'll get massive, and I was like, no. What? Yeah. Really? Get your nose pierced for points?
我大儿子几周前做这个的时候跟我说，嘿，我能去穿个鼻钉吗，因为我能得超高分，然后我说，不。什么？对。真的吗？为了得分去穿个鼻钉？
Yeah. I think one of the funniest ones was if you make out with one of the parents. Oh, parents, okay. Really? I self-wrote that in. You can read it. Yeah, I get it.
对。我觉得最搞笑的一个是，如果你跟其中一个家长舌吻。哦，家长，好吧。真的吗？我自己把这个写进去了。你可以读一下。对，我懂。
And he left his door open. What a forensic handwriting check for Jason on that one. It was also to drink a shot of certain bodily fluids as well, which is good. Oh, wow. Yeah, I know, yeah, I was disgusted. Jesus Christ. I thought, what the fuck are these young people doing
然后他把门开着。对杰森的那份字迹进行了一次法医笔迹鉴定。还得喝一杯某种体液，这也挺好。哦，哇。是啊，我知道，是的，我觉得很恶心。天哪。我想，这些年轻人到底在搞什么鬼
these days? I know. Wait, so Stephen, I'm gonna, this is somebody here in L.A.'s house's daughter? Yes. No, no,, I'm gonna need, this is somebody here in LA's house's daughter? Yes. No, no, no, no, no. No, it was a friend's sister who was telling me about, and my sister was telling us about what it was.
这些天？我知道。等等，所以斯蒂芬，我打算，这是洛杉矶某人家女儿的？对。不，不，不，不，不。不，是一个朋友的姐姐在跟我讲，是我姐姐在跟我们讲这是怎么回事。
Wow. Now do you have kids, Stephen? I do, yeah, and thank God mine don't do any discovered shit. Well hang on, are they old enough yet? How old are they? Yeah, yeah, yeah, Alfie's 18 and Grace is 20. And so you're saying they never did anything like this
哇。那你现在有孩子吗，斯蒂芬？我有，是的，谢天谢地，我的孩子不做任何这种恶心的破事。等等，他们到年龄了吗？他们多大了？对，对，对，阿尔菲 18 岁，格蕾丝 20 岁。所以你是说他们从来没有做过这样的事
in high school? We just don't have that kind of behavior where I come from, Jason. I think they're- It's normal, that's normal, you're normal. I don't think they're being honest with you, Steven. Jason, one of the major things my children are is honest.
在高中时？我们那没有那种行为，杰森。我觉得他们——这很正常，这很正常，你是正常的。我觉得他们没对你讲实话，斯蒂芬。杰森，我的孩子们最大的特点之一就是诚实。
Now we do the Mooney, which is like, stick your ass out of a window, that's as far as we go. Right, right, right. What do you ever do, or against a window, which is a pressed ham? Well, yeah. Yeah. I've never heard of that.
现在我们做的是“亮屁股”，就像把屁股伸出窗外，这就是我们的极限了。对，对，对。或者靠着窗户，也就是“压制火腿”。好吧，对。对。我从来没听说过这个。
That was always on a bus, though. That was on a bus, that one. On a bus, we would do the pressed ham. Yeah, you'd do that one on a bus. And then, but then the worst thing was you'd do it, and then the car that you did it to would pull alongside you later on in the traffic. And yeah, we used to do that when we'd go to football.
不过那总是在公交车上。那是在公交车上，那个。在公交车上，我们会做“压制火腿”。对，你会一直在公交车上做那个。然后，但最糟糕的是你做了，然后你针对的那辆车后来在交通中跟你并行了。对，我们以前去看足球赛时经常这么做。
Yeah. What would be the name if you pressed it against the window and you spread it? What would be the name there? Oh God. Oh my God. Sliced ham. Yeah, there you go.
对。如果你把它按在玻璃上然后把它摊开，叫什么名字？那个叫什么名字？哦，天哪。哦，天哪。切片火腿。对，这就对了。
Thanks. That's what I'm here for. Steven, first of all, thanks for being here. By the way, I just found out this morning, I found this out this morning, first of all, congrats on your recent Gotham Award. And Adolescents is the second most watched show of all time on Netflix.
谢谢。我就是为此而来的。斯蒂芬，首先，谢谢你能来。顺便说一句，我今天早上刚发现的，我今天早上发现了这个，首先，祝贺你最近获得哥谭奖。而且《青春期》是 Netflix 史上观看次数第二多的剧集。
That's awesome. No way. Yeah, that's crazy. That's amazing. Well deserved. What an accomplishment. What an accomplishment. I mean, truly, I mean, and I know you've talked about this a lot, because I've seen it out there, and I watch the show, it's fantastic, you're fantastic've seen it out there and I've watched the show. It's fantastic, you're fantastic.
太棒了。不会吧。对，太疯狂了。太棒了。实至名归。多么了不起的成就。多么了不起的成就。我的意思是，真的，我的意思是，我知道你经常谈论这个，因为我在外面看到过，而且我看过这部剧，太棒了，你太棒了，我在外面看到过，我也看过这部剧。太棒了，你太棒了。
Also the co-creator of the show. Yeah, incredible. Which is no small feat. For people to understand, they might see the credit and the creator and you think like, okay, well, that's just another hat. It's the amount of work and thought and years and preparation that goes into just being
同时也是该剧的联合创作者。对，难以置信。这可不是一件小事。为了让人们理解，他们可能会看到演职员表上的创作者，然后你会觉得，好吧，那只是另一个头衔。仅仅作为一部剧的创作者所需要付出的工作量、思考、年复一年的准备工作，更不用说还要参演其中了。
the creator of the show and then on top to being in it. And then on top of that, doing it, shooting it all in effect live in one shot is so impressive. So, and I know you've talked ad nauseum about that aspect of doing it, but for people to really understand what it takes to pull off doing an entire episode, each episode of that program live
最厉害的是，把它拍出来，整部剧实际上都是一镜到底的现场拍摄，太震撼了。所以，我知道你已经对拍摄的那个方面滔滔不绝地谈过了，但为了让人们真正理解要完成整整一集，该节目的每一集都现场拍摄
as if it were happening, well, it was happening in real time and not just in one location, but getting into vehicles and moving to different locations. Everything that goes in that, the preparation that must've gone into that. When you came up with the idea of the show, was that part and parcel with it? Was it like, we're going to do this show,
就好像它正在发生一样，好吧，它是在实时发生，而且不仅在一个地点，还要上车移动到不同的地方。所有这一切，其中包含的准备工作。当你萌生出这部剧的想法时，那是其中不可或缺的一部分吗？是不是就像，我们要拍这部剧，
tell this story, and we're going to do it this way? Well, to be honest with you, Will, we did a, the whole thing kind of began with me doing a favor for a friend, actually. My mate, Phil Barantini, he was an actor, and he just, one day, he just phoned me up, and he said, look, I really want to direct. Would you help me out in being a short film?
讲这个故事，而且我们要用这种方式来拍？好吧，老实说，威利，我们做了一个，整个事情的开始其实是我在帮一个朋友的忙。我的哥们菲尔·巴兰蒂尼（Phil Barantini），他是个演员，有一天他给我打电话说，听着，我真的很想当导演。你能帮我拍一部短片吗？
And I said no. Which is what you should do. I said no. He was like, well go make your first short film and then we'll have a look and then we'll talk again. Good for you. I don't want to be part of the experiment. Of course, but it's also, Jay, you know,
我说不。这正是你该做的。我说不。他就像，那去拍你的第一部短片，然后我们再看看，然后再谈。真为你高兴。我不想成为实验的一部分。当然，这也是，杰、你知道的，
it's that kind of, show me what you can do first. Exactly. So he did, he went, and he made this beautiful, but also though, he was asking me if I would play the trainer to a boxer, and the lad who was going to play the main role was a boxer and an actor, and I said, well, doesn't Robbie have a trainer?
那种，先展示一下你能做什么。没错。所以他去了，他拍了这部美丽的，但同时，他问我是否愿意扮演一个拳击手的教练，而那个将要扮演主角的小伙子既是一个拳击手也是个演员，我说，难道罗比没有教练吗？
And he was like, yeah. I was like, well, just use Robbie's real fucking trainer. And he was like, well, I went, because he knows what he's doing. I said, has he got a good face? He went, yeah, he looks great. I went, well, cast him then. And he's like, oh.
他当时说，有啊。我说，那就用罗比现实中他妈的真教练呗。然后他说，呃，因为他知道自己在做什么。我说，他长了一张好脸吗？他说，对，他看起来很棒。我说，那就选他演呗。他就像，哦。
Yeah, I got shit to do. That's a really good idea. I was like, yeah, just use him. They've got a relationship, so we did. Anyway, and it was really good. But to get to the point, Matt, who he'd met, the DOP had this glorious idea of doing a short film in one take, but setting it in a restaurant.
好吧，我还有一堆事要忙。那真的是个好主意。我说，对，就用他。他们本来就有联系，所以我们就用了。不管怎样，这真的很棒。但说重点，马特，他遇到的那个摄影指导（DOP）有个绝妙的主意，想拍一部一镜到底的短片，但背景设在一家餐厅里。
So again, Phil said, look, Matt's had this wonderful idea. I think it'd be really good, because Phil used to work in the restaurant industry. He was a chef for a long time. And it was just this concept about a shift at work, and this man going through a bit of, you know, lots of troubles at home and trying to navigate that in work. And also he has his own addictions and stuff.
所以菲尔又说，听着，马特有个极好的主意。我觉得这会非常棒，因为菲尔以前在餐饮业工作过。他当了很长时间的厨师。这个概念是关于工作中的一个班次，这个男人在家里经历了一些，你知道的，很多麻烦，并试图在工作中应对这些。而且他还有自己的瘾头之类的问题。
So it was like, look, we'll shoot it in 22 minutes. That's how long the day is going to be. And I was like, that sounds great. How many days? And he went, five. I said, I'll give you three. He was like, oh, okay. I went, we can shoot it in three. So we did, we shot it in three.
所以当时就像，听着，我们会在 22 分钟内拍完。这一天就是这么长。我觉得这听起来不错。几天？他说，五天。我说，我给你三天。他当时说，哦，好吧。我说，我们可以在三天内拍完。所以我们做到了，我们在三天内拍完了它。
And the primary purpose of it was to try and use it as a calling card to get Phil an agent. So I give it to my agent, she sent it around the office and then literally within four to five days he was having meetings and he then got his agent, Jaygo. And that was how it happened. So it was all starting to do a favor for a friend and then Jaygo said, why don't we turn this into a feature?
它的主要目的其实是想把它当成一块敲门砖，帮菲尔找个经纪人。所以我把它给了我的经纪人，她在办公室里传阅了它，字面意义上在四到五天内他就开始开会了，然后他找到了他的经纪人杰戈（Jaygo）。事情就是这样发生的。所以这一切都始于帮朋友一个忙，然后杰戈说，我们为什么不把它拍成一部长片呢？
So we did a little indie film called Boiling Point. And just to go to that, you never know what can happen from these things as we all know with this industry, you just don't know. Cut to three years down the line, four years down the line, we're sat at BAFTA and films nominated for best actor, the films up for best British film.
于是我们拍了一部名为《沸点》（Boiling Point）的小成本独立电影。顺便说一句，正如我们这个行业的每个人所知，你永远不知道这些事情会带来什么，你就是不知道。快进到三年后，四年后，我们坐在英国电影学院奖（BAFTA）的典礼上，电影被提名最佳男主角，电影入围最佳英国电影。
I'm nominated alongside Will Smith and Leonardo DiCaprio and Benedict Cumberbatch, all for doing a mate a favor. And so we had proof of concept with that particular piece and then we were asked if we would be interested in turning it into a television show. And that's basically how it all began. So then, Boiling Point is similar to the story in Adolescence?
我跟威尔·史密斯、莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥和本尼迪克特·康伯巴奇一同获得提名，全都是因为帮了一个朋友的忙。所以我们通过那个特定的作品验证了概念，然后我们被问到是否有兴趣把它拍成电视剧。这基本上就是一切的开始。所以，那《沸点》跟《青春期》的故事类似吗？
It's a completely different story, but it's all shot in that one take format, and that's more controlled. It's an environment, it's all set in a restaurant, in a kitchen and in a restaurant, and it's this one particular shift. And I think the film is an hour and, maybe an hour and 15? And the thinking behind the creative effect
这是一个完全不同的故事，但它完全是用那种一镜到底的格式拍摄的，而且控制得更多。这是一个环境，完全设定在餐厅里，厨房和餐厅里，这就是特定的一个班次。我觉得这部电影有一个小时，也许一个小时 15 分钟？而你们追求的创作效果背后的想法
that you guys were aiming for by having it all intact in one take and not distracting the audience with any cuts whatsoever or coverage or anything like that, was what? Did you guys ever kind of put words to the purpose behind only one take, aside from just like the incredible rush, the creative challenge of that? I think that was it, basically, Jason, to be honest with you. It's that kind of trying to grab the audience's attention straight away.
是通过保持整体一镜到底、完全不通过任何剪辑来分散观众注意力，或者通过覆盖镜头或诸如此类的东西，这是为了什么？你们有没有把这种单一镜头的目的用言语表达出来，除了那种令人难以置信的冲动、创作上的挑战之外？我想基本上就是这样，杰森，老实说。就是那种试图立刻抓住观众注意力的感觉。
And you have kids, I have kids, and we live in an age where we'll be watching a film, but yet they're still looking at the phones. And it's kind of like, put that down, we're trying to watch a film in many ways. Do you know what I mean? So it was that wanting to grab the audience's attention, but also make sure that it wasn to grab the audience's attention, it's like we all jump on a train doesn't have a purpose to move. It's like we all jump on a train and then we don't get off until we finish.
你有孩子，我也有孩子，我们生活在这样一个时代：我们会在看电影的同时还在看手机。这就像是，放下那个，我们正在努力看电影呢。你知道我的意思吗？所以这就是想要抓住观众的注意力，同时也要确保它不是——就像我们都跳上一列没有移动目的的火车。就像我们都跳上一列火车，直到结束才下车。
But for people to appreciate, and we all work in this medium so we understand, but to really appreciate the difficulty, not just the closing of the roads, not just the hiding crew and camera and all that kind of stuff, but the light changes, for instance. By the way, there is that, am I wrong? Did I, did I imagine it? There were light changes when the, your son, the actor's name is, is it Owen?
但为了让人们欣赏——我们都在这个行业工作，所以我们懂——但真正去欣赏其中的难度，不仅是封锁街道，不仅是隐藏剧组、摄像机和所有这些乱七八糟的东西，还有光线变化，举个例子。顺便说一句，确实有那个，我错了吗？我是不是，我是不是想象出来的？当你的儿子——演员的名字是，是欧文吗？
Owen Cooper, yeah. Oh, Owen Cooper, who's brilliant. Owen Cooper, when he gets moody, did the light darken in those moments? Am I right about that, or is that obvious, or? Owen Cooper is brilliant. the psychological aspect of it just changing slightly dramatically within the cell. Was that a lighting cue or was it an iris ride? It's a lighting cue kind of. It's a lighting cue within the police station,
欧文·库珀，是的。哦，欧文·库珀，他太棒了。欧文·库珀情绪低落时，那一刻的灯光变暗了吗？我是这么觉得的，还是这很明显？欧文·库珀太棒了。心理层面只是在牢房里发生了微妙而戏剧性的变化。那是灯光提示还是光圈调整？这有点像灯光提示。这是警察局里的一个灯光提示，
within the cell when he's brought into the cell. I mean think about that JB. I mean think about making that call. So you're doing all that stuff, you have all these, and then in the moment you've got to get it right. There's basically a lighting cue in the middle of it. There's so many elements happening at once. The logistics.
当他被带进牢房时，在牢房里。我的意思是，想想看，JB。我是说想想怎么打那通电话。所以你做了所有这些事情，你有了所有这些，然后在那个时刻你必须把它做好。中间基本上有一个灯光提示。有这么多元素同时发生。后勤工作。
Yeah, the logistics. Logistics. Yeah. We'll be right back. And now back to the show. And so the obvious question which I had, which how many takes did you do? I mean, I'd be so afraid to be the one to screw it up. Well, the beauty of it, I mean, and it was also,
是的，物流。物流。是的。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以显而易见的问题是，你们拍了多少条？我的意思是，我会非常害怕成为那个搞砸的人。嗯，它的妙处在于，我的意思是，而且这也是，
look, it was beautifully written by Jack, Jack Thorne, our wonderful writer, who constructs the human condition so beautifully and so amazingly. And we had that kind of discussion right at the very beginning what it was going to be and how we were going to try to put this story across without pointing any fingers, but it's just that kind of accountability of parents,
听着，杰克——杰克·索恩，我们出色的编剧，把剧本写得太美了，他构建人类生存状况的手法是那么精妙绝伦。我们在最开始就讨论过这部剧的定位，以及我们将如何尝试在不指责任何人的前提下把这个故事讲好，但其中正包含着为人父母的那种责任感，
maybe the parents are accountable. There's the school system, the education system, the society and the community where they live and also the government and also on top of that, you have the internet, which none of us had when we were kids. So we've never had to navigate that kind of thing. If an incident happened in school, it was kind of thing.
也许家长们应该负责。还有学校系统、教育系统、他们生活的社会和社区，以及政府，除此之外，还有互联网，这是我们小时候都没有的。所以我们从来不需要应对那种事情。如果学校发生了一起事件，那就是那种情况。
If an incident happened in school, it was kind of finished by the end of when the bell went, and then you'd pick it up again the next day. Hopefully it didn't continue too much. happening in school. director and just discuss the words. Yeah, well that's exactly what it is. It's that beautiful process of being a theater company and having this brand new script. So we take it to pieces. It's kind of like analyzing every single word like you would a Chekhov play and understanding the importance of it and why it's there and why it's being said.
如果校园里发生了什么事，基本上在放学铃响的时候就告一段落了，然后第二天再继续。希望这种事不要持续太久。发生在学校里。导演然后一起讨论台词。对，这正是它的意义所在。这是一个美妙的过程，作为一个戏剧剧团，拿到了一份全新的剧本。所以我们把它拆解开来。这有点像去剖析每一个字，就像对待契诃夫的戏剧一样，去理解它的重要性、它为什么存在以及它为什么会被说出来。
of that week having a whole dress rehearsal. And by the end of that week, by that following Friday, we'll go for a little take, we'll see what happens. And then when you get back in on the Monday, we go for two takes a day. So you do one in the morning about half 10, have lunch, reset, and then come back again in the afternoon. So it's a beautiful experience. So ultimately we were looking at hopefully trying
那一周要进行完整的彩排。到了那一周结束时，也就是接下来的周五，我们会去进行一个小试拍，看看效果如何。然后当你周一回来时，我们一天进行两次试拍。所以你早上十点半左右拍一次，吃午饭，重置，然后下午再来一次。所以这是一次美好的经历。所以最终我们希望能够尝试
to get 10 takes by the end of the week. But episodes two, 3 and 4 were all the final take of each one. Oh wow. So it was that final Friday. So I think take episode 2 was take 14. Wow. And it was the only time that the drone actually got attached to the camera, got attached to the drone, it flew up.
为了在周末结束前完成10个镜头。但是第2、3和4集都是各自的最后一个镜头。哦，哇。所以那是最后的周五。我想第2集是第14个镜头。哇。而且这也是无人机唯一一次真正装到相机上，装到无人机上，然后飞了上去。
I don't know if you remember that in the school where it flies up in the air and then it comes down and then it gets taken by the camera department and it comes to where I'm stood with the flowers. It's insane, it's insane. Now imagine that though, Will. I mean, the wind had been shit, so we didn't have a take at all.
我不知道你是否记得，在那个学校里，它飞到空中然后落下来，接着被摄影部门拿走，来到了我拿着花站着的地方。这太疯狂了，简直疯狂。威尔，想象一下那个情景吧。我的意思是，当时风太糟糕了，所以我们根本没拍成。
So it's the final Friday afternoon, and it's all going great. And I'm sat in the van, beating an executive producer, listening to Sarah on the radio, okay, go. So we've got the kids coming out the thing, and I'm listening to it all, and it's like, okay, that's good, that's good. And then it's like, okay, drone's attached, the drone's up, and I'm like sitting there going, okay, so the drone's up. And then I see it, and I see the drone, I'm like, oh wow, okay, drone's attached, the drone's up, and I'm like sitting there going, okay, so the drone's up. And then I see it, and I see the drone,
所以这是最后一个周五下午，一切进展顺利。我坐在面包车里，痛击一位执行制片人，听着收音机里的莎拉，好吧，开始。所以我们有孩子们从那个东西里出来，我听着这一切，心想，好吧，这很好，这很好。然后就像，好吧，无人机已经装好，无人机起飞了，我坐在那里想着，好吧，无人机起飞了。然后我看到了它，我看到了无人机，我心想，哦哇，好吧，无人机已经装好，无人机起飞了，我坐在那里想着，好吧，无人机起飞了。然后我看到了它，我看到了无人机，
I'm like, oh wow, okay, so the drone. And then I see the van coming round the corner, I see all the fellas jump out the van, I see Matt run over as the drone, they catch the drone, Matt takes the camera and then I go, oh shit, I'm in it, oh my God. And then I, yeah, I remember that was in it, and I've grabbed the flowers, composed myself,
我想，哦哇，好吧，原来是无人机。然后我看到面包车转过弯来，我看到所有家伙从面包车里跳出来，我看到马特跑向无人机，他们抓住了无人机，马特拿走了摄像机，然后我想，哦天哪，我入镜了，我的天哪。然后我，是的，我记起我也在里面，我抓起花，镇定下来，
and then I've opened the door and got out. And we managed to get that take. But the picture went off when the drum was attached. So everybody back at bass had no idea that we'd completed the scene. Right, right. They were just holding their breath. They were just panicking. It's so, I mean, just aside from just all the logistics, the sequencing and all the planning and all that stuff,
然后我打开门走了出去。我们设法完成了那个镜头。但是当连接上鼓机时，画面却消失了。所以基地里的每个人都不知道我们已经完成了这个场景。对，对。他们当时都在屏住呼吸。他们都在恐慌。这真是，我是说，抛开所有的后勤保障、镜头顺序、所有的计划以及所有这些东西不谈，
the fun of that and the excitement of that, but specifically for this subject matter and the way that the scripts are constructed in this linear storytelling, it's A goes to B goes to C goes to D, and you're, as you said, on a train, and you never get off, you're never tapped on the shoulder by an edit and knocked out of your trance.
这种乐趣和兴奋感，尤其是针对这个主题，以及这种线性叙事中剧本的构建方式，即A到B到C再到D，正如你所说，就像在一列永不停车的火车上，你永远不会被剪辑拍肩膀而从沉浸感中惊醒。
You're staying in this one shot, and you're stuck in the best sense of the word, and you can't stop watching, and it's just, it's so propulsive watching and it's just so propulsive and it's such a perfect concept to use this device. JB, I'll add to that which is that I think that linear storytelling is something that we kind of take for granted
你留在这个长镜头里，在这个最好的意义上被吸引住了，你无法停止观看，它是如此具有推动力，观看它是如此具有推动力，使用这个技巧是一个如此完美的构思。JB，我还要补充一点，我认为线性叙事是我们有点理所当然的事情
and we sort of try to get away from and try to dress stuff up and there is something because of the way that you told it and there is no cut to distract you, but also because it's happening in real time, you feel less like you're watching it and more like you're in it. Yeah, exactly.
我们试图摆脱这些，把事情包装起来，正是因为你讲述的方式，没有剪辑来分散你的注意力，而且因为它是在实时发生的，你感觉不那么像是在观看，而更像是身临其境。是的，完全正确。
And so it's much more immersive in that way. You feel like you're, do you know what I mean? You're not, it's not performative, it's not something that you're not observing, you're actually in it. Yeah, and given the subject matter, it's very... Visceral. Yeah, you're so affected.
所以这种方式更具沉浸感。你会觉得自己正在，你知道我的意思吗？你不是在，这不是一种表演，这不是你在旁观的事情，你实际上身处其中。是的，考虑到这个主题，它是非常……发自肺腑的。是的，你深受触动。
It's like you just step on the audience's neck and you don't get off, it's outstanding. That was, thank you very much, they're lovely things for you both to say. That was kind of one of the things we thought of at the very beginning, and like I say, Jack's one of my favorite writers of all time. He's a wonderful man.
就像你踩在观众的脖子上不下来一样，太出色了。那是，非常感谢，这些都是你们两个人的可爱评价。这差不多是我们一开始就想到的事情之一，就像我说的，杰克是我有史以来最喜欢的作家之一。他是个非常棒的人。
I've worked with him six times. Jack's idea as we create the story was to grab the audience. He said what it gave him as a writer was a lot of freedom because a writer is totally ... With writing that script, he's totally in kind of control of not just what the story is, but also the rhythm of how it moves and how it's set and the kind of pace of it. And then you're just amazed, like you said, it's that kind of voyeuristic element. But as well, conventionally, you know, the story would be told, but it'd be slightly disjointed and you could go to any point in time. But when I said from the very beginning, look,
我和他合作过六次。我们在创作这个故事时，杰克的想法是吸引观众。他说，作为一名作家，这给了他很大的自由，因为作家完全……在编写那个剧本时，他完全掌控的不仅是故事本身，还有故事推进的节奏、场景的设置以及它的步伐。然后你会感到惊叹，就像你说的，那种窥探性的元素。但同样，按常规来说，故事会被讲述出来，但会有点脱节，你可以去到任何时间点。但当我从一开始就说，听着，
this goes over 13 months and we're just going to grab the audience four times in this story, but it's going to be for an hour. And we allow the, I think what we did as well was like, you know, treating the audience with respect and with intelligence, let them fill in the gaps. And it doesn't have the answers and it wasn't open. And as an actor, was it exciting to be inside of the tape? let them fill in the gaps. And it doesn't have the answers. And it wasn't open.
这跨越了13个月的时间，在这个故事里我们只打算四次抓住观众，每次持续一个小时。我们允许，我觉得我们所做的还有，你知道的，以尊重和智慧对待观众，让他们去填补空白。它没有给出答案，而且也不是开放式的。作为一名演员，置身于录音带之中是否令人兴奋？让他们去填补空白。而且它没有给出答案。而且它也不是开放式的。
And as an actor, was it exciting to be inside of the take, of the one hour, knowing that no one can get to you, just like theater. So between action and cut, you're dictating the pace, the rhythm, the timing, everything. It'll never be changed. It'll never be manipulated by an editor's choice or a director's choice or a scene won't be cut.
而且作为一个演员，身处这样一个一气呵成、长达一小时的长镜头中，是不是很令人兴奋？那种感觉就像在剧场里一样，你知道没有人能打扰你。所以在“开始”和“停”之间，你掌控着节奏、韵律、时机以及一切。这一切永远不会被改变，永远不会被剪辑师的选择或导演的选择所操纵，场景也不会被剪掉。
So all of your ideas about how you're gonna arc out your performance is completely in your control. Well, you worked it out beforehand though. I mean like- Yeah, but still, but like each, you say you do this multiple times. Yeah, but JV is right, like once it's rolling. Yeah exactly, so each take can be completely different. I mean everybody has to hit their marks
所以你对于如何安排表演弧光的所有想法，完全在你的掌控之中。好吧，不过你之前就排练过了。我的意思是——对，但还是那样，而且每，你说你排练了好多次。对，但JV说得对，一旦开始运转。对，完全没错，所以每次拍摄都可以完全不同。我的意思是每个人都得站到位
because of all the technical sequencing, but there's still, there's just performance stuff you know is going to be married to this particular version of this episode. This particular take will always be, my reaction to her line is always going to be that. It's not going to be taken from take two, married to her reading in take seven.
因为所有的技术编排，但依然有，就是那些你知道会和这一特定版本的这一集融为一体的表演细节。这次拍摄将永远是这样，我对她的台词的反应将永远是那样。它不会采用第二次拍摄的画面，去和她第七次拍摄的念白剪辑在一起。
Like it's all unique to that one piece. It's kind of cool, yeah. Yeah, you've hit the nail on the end, because as we all know, when you perform, we're not in control of the choices that get made. Yeah. Which we all understand, choices that get made. Which we all understand, and that's great.
就好像这一切都是那个片段独一无二的。这挺酷的，对吧。对，你一针见血，因为正如我们所知，当你表演时，我们无法控制最后会被采用的选择。对。我们都理解，最后被采用的选择。我们都理解，这很棒。
They take the little bits like you just perfectly described. But with the process of this, and again, back in Sean as well, we have that wonderful rehearsal process, like we would with a play. But then you're right, on the day, no take was identical to the others. Because what it does, and again, I'm a working class kid from Liverpool, you know what I mean? I can't say I'm pretentious. By the way, you never run the risk of sounding pretentious. Yes, well you're good. Just for clarity.
他们会像你刚才完美描述的那样，挑选那些小片段。但在这一过程中，还是回到肖恩的话，我们有那种美妙的排练过程，就像排话剧一样。但接着你说得对，到了拍摄当天，没有哪一次拍摄和其他的完全一样。因为它的作用是，再次强调，我是个来自利物浦的工人阶级孩子，你知道我的意思吗？我可不能说自己是个矫情的人。顺便说一句，你从来没有听起来很矫情的风险。没错，你很棒。为了把话说清楚。
All right, good. But it's, now give me a moment, because I may do, but it's the most zen I've ever felt as an actor, and it also puts you right in that place. No, you did it. You did it. You did do it. You did do it.
好吧，很好。但这，现在给我点时间，因为我可能会有，但这是我作为演员感到最禅意的一次，而且它也把你直接带入了那种状态。不，你做到了。你做到了。你确实做到了。你确实做到了。
Thanks for joining us, Stephen. Look, that's what my microphone's leading on. Do you know what I mean? So it's not I'm just saying it for shits and giggles. That's me speaking. I love that. So in the same respect, it's that kind of, you're completely, like you said,
谢谢你加入我们，斯蒂芬。听着，那是我的麦克风在带着节奏。你知道我的意思吗？所以我不是在胡说八道。那是我在说话。我太喜欢这个了。所以在同样的层面上，就是那种，你完全，就像你说的，
well, it's that immersive experience for the audience, but picking up on you, J, it is for the actor, because you have to be present, truly present. And what it does is, to me, acting is all about listening and reacting, do you know what I mean? So you're constantly listening and reacting to what's being, what's in front of you. As you know, Steven, I had this discussion
嗯，那是给观众的沉浸式体验，但说到你，杰，这也是给演员的，因为你必须在场，真正地在场。而它的作用是，对我来说，表演全在于倾听和反应，你知道我的意思吗？所以你一直在倾听和反应正在发生的事情，在你面前的事情。如你所知，斯蒂芬，我和
with somebody very recently, they said, oh, is it hard to memorize lines? I was talking about this, having lots of dialogue, and Jay, I know you just came up with something where you had a lot of dialogue, and the truth is, as we all know, it's not hard when, if you're present, and the person says something to you,
某个人不久前讨论过这个，他们说，哦，背台词难吗？我当时在谈论这个，有大量的台词，杰，我知道你最近刚拍完一个有很多台词的项目，事实是，我们都知道，如果你在场，当别人对你说话时，台词并不难，
you're, what you're going to say next makes sense to them. You don't have to memorize, because it makes sense what you should say. Yeah. If the writing's good. Do you know what I mean? If the writing's good. Yeah, if the writing's good. Yeah. Yeah.
你接下来要说的话对他们来说是有意义的。你不需要死记硬背，因为你该说的话在情理之中。对。如果剧本好的话。你知道我的意思吗？如果剧本好的话。对，如果剧本好的话。对。对。
But that's what I love about your process about like it being like theater. You can discuss like, I don't know that I would say that. I would say, I feel like this would make more sense. And that collaborative experience probably made it all the better. Completely. Yeah, tell me about, wait,
但这就是我喜欢你们的创作过程的地方，它就像戏剧一样。你可以讨论，比如说，我不知道我会不会那样说。我会说，我觉得这样会更有意义。这种合作体验可能会让它变得更好。完全是这样。对，告诉我，等等，
so I wanna talk about break dancing. First of all, what's Scouse? So, like Scouse is what? What's Scouse? Is that a, is that? Scouse is like a terminology for the particular type of person who comes from Liverpool. We have different-
所以我想谈谈霹雳舞。首先，什么是Scouse？所以，Scouse是什么？什么是Scouse？这是一个，这是一个？Scouse是用来形容来自利物浦的特定类型人群的术语。我们有不同的——
Oh, it's like a subset of- Well, it's like, you know, if you're from Liverpool, you're called a Scouser. If you're from Newcastle, you're called a Geordie. Oh, okay, okay. If you're, it's like, you know, if you're from Liverpool, you're called a Scouser. If you're from Newcastle, you're called a Geordie. Oh, okay, okay. If you're from London, you used to be called a Cotney. Do you know what I mean? Oh, right, right, right.
哦，这就像是——嗯，这就像是，你知道的，如果你来自利物浦，你被称为Scouser。如果你来自纽卡斯尔，你被称为Geordie。哦，好吧，好吧。如果你，这就像是，你知道的，如果你来自利物浦，你被称为Scouser。如果你来自纽卡斯尔，你被称为Geordie。哦，好吧，好吧。如果你来自伦敦，你以前被称为Cockney。你知道我的意思吗？哦，对，对，对。
All right. And if you're from Scotland, you're called a Geoch. Why? So it's different kind of saying. Where'd all these come from? Like if you're from Beverly Hills, you're called the Douche. Right. Right.
好吧。如果你来自苏格兰，你被称为Geoch。为什么？所以这是不同的说法。这些都是从哪来的？就像如果你来自比弗利山庄，你被称为混蛋。对。对。
So... Yeah. So. Yeah. So, no, it is, so yeah, Scouser is. So Scouser is someone who comes from Liverpool, yeah. Okay, I don't know. Who's like a true Liverpoolian who has a, you know, who's, right? Yeah, yeah, that's it, you know.
所以……对。所以。对。所以，不，它是，所以是的，Scouser是。所以Scouser是来自利物浦的人，对。好吧，我不知道。就像一个真正的利物浦人，他有，你知道的，他是，对吧？对，对，就是这样，你知道的。
Working class, full. Why do people think you're faking the accent when I, like what? I have no idea, it's hard for me, he spoke so to me. That's so weird. I don't know, never heard that one. All right, tell me about breakdancing
工人阶级，全套。为什么人们会觉得我在假装口音呢，就像什么？我不知道，这对我来说很难，他对我说话的方式。太奇怪了。我不知道，从没听过这个。好吧，跟我讲讲霹雳舞
because I did it too and I would absorb the pain and then walk away like that was really fun, but I've been in so much pain. Like I never did the head spins or anything, but I constantly was breakdancing. It was just, it was just. We did this as kids. Because he did it in Liverpool and I did it like,
因为我也跳过，我会承受那种痛苦然后走开，就觉得这真的很有趣，但我当时痛苦极了。就像我从来没做过头转什么的，但我一直在跳霹雳舞。这只是，这只是。我们小时候都干过这事。因为他在利物浦跳过，而我跳过，就像，
I was like, when I read that I was like, I did that kids. Because he did it in Liverpool, and I did it like, I was like, when I read that I was like, I did that too, that's so crazy. Where was you when you did your break dancing? Oh, anywhere. Anywhere there was a mall. Like a dinner theater. Anywhere there was a piece of cardboard,
我当时想，当我读到那段时，我就想，我小时候也干过这事。因为他在利物浦跳过，而我跳过，就像，我当时想，当我读到那段时，我就想，我也干过这事，这太疯狂了。你跳霹雳舞的时候在哪儿？哦，到处都是。任何有商场的地方。比如晚餐剧场。任何有一块硬纸板的地方，
I would just go watch this, do the worm. We even bought lino, so you know the lino that people used to put in the kitchens back in the 80s. We used to carry our own bit of lino. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And get it all blasted. It was like back in the days of Electro 7 and Grandmaster Flash and Melly Merlin and the Furies 5 and all that kind of stuff. And we just, yeah, I don't know, it was just this whole thing that just popped up.
我就会去看这个，跳毛毛虫舞。我们甚至买过油毡，所以你知道80年代人们铺在厨房里的那种油毡。我们以前随身带着自己的一小块油毡。对，对，对。然后把它铺开。那就像是电音7号、宗师闪现（Grandmaster Flash）、梅利·梅林（Melle Mel）、狂怒五子（The Furious Five）以及诸如此类的年代。我们当时就，对，我不知道，这只是一个突然冒出来的热潮。
Obviously it came over from America. And it ended up in a little town where I'm from, Kirby. And we used to go and do it in the town center. Because we couldn't watch videos and nothing like that to work out what they were doing. So I don't even know how we, I think it got past that. But now it's an Olympic sport. Isn't that funny?
很显然它是从美国传过来的。最后传到了我老家一个小镇柯比（Kirkby）。我们经常去镇中心跳。因为我们看不到录像带之类的东西来研究他们在做什么。所以我甚至不知道我们是怎么，我想它是跨越了那个阶段。但现在它成了一项奥运会运动。这不是很搞笑吗？
Yeah, that video. You know how good it is, it's amazing, isn't it? It's pretty amazing. Well, it's at a nice level. How were the outfits? Were you proud of your outfits and your hairdos? Yeah, I used to have a shiny shell suit back in the day. Yeah, something that you could spin on,
对，那个视频。你知道它有多好吗，太惊人了，不是吗？相当惊人。嗯，水平挺不错的。服装怎么样？你为自己的服装和发型感到骄傲吗？对，我以前有一套亮闪闪的防风衣。对，那种你可以躺在上面旋转的，
do you know what I mean? And then the parachute pants and like, yeah. Sean, were you in like an Adidas tracksuit or were you like MC Hammer pants? No, no, but I did have parachute pants because I thought they were really cool. Yeah. I used to have a really lovely velour Adidas.
你知道我的意思吗？然后是降落伞裤之类的，对吧。肖恩，你当时是穿阿迪达斯运动服，还是像MC Hammer那样的裤子？不，不，不过我确实有降落伞裤，因为我觉得它们真的很酷。对。我以前有一件非常好看的天鹅绒阿迪达斯。
Oh yeah. Oh nice. Velour. You wear that straight to bed. Yeah. Yeah, it's lovely. So you grew up in Liverpool or outside of Liverpool. Kirkby, where's Kirkby?
哦，是的。哦，真不错。丝绒。你直接穿着它睡觉。对。对，这很可爱。所以你在利物浦长大还是在利物浦郊外。柯比，柯比在哪里？
Kirby, it's just kind of like 35 minutes from the city center. So you know, Stephen, you must know John Bishop. Not personally, but I've met him a couple of times socially but I don't know him personally. Okay, that's the guy you did the film that's based on, Willie? Yes, who's also a Scouser.
柯比，离市中心大约只有35分钟的路程。所以你知道，斯蒂芬，你一定知道约翰·毕肖普。虽然不认识，但在社交场合见过几次，但我不认识他本人。好的，就是那个你拍的电影的原型，威利吗？是的，他也是个利物浦人。
Yeah, the film that we did is based on his life, yeah. His story. When's this film coming out? But I thought you would. Fairly soon. The film that we did is based on his life, his story. But I thought you would. I met John by chance and he told me a story of how he became a stand-up comedian, which is kind of an interesting story, by mistake. He was separated from his wife and they were getting divorced and he went to do stand up. He went to go for a drink
是的，我们拍的那部电影就是根据他的生平改编的，是的。他的故事。这部电影什么时候上映？但我以为你会的。挺快的。我们拍的那部电影是根据他的生平、他的故事改编的。但我以为你会的。我和约翰是一次偶然的机会认识的，他告诉我他是如何阴差阳错成为一名单口喜剧演员的，这是一个挺有趣的故事。他和妻子分居了，正在办理离婚，然后他去说了单口喜剧。他去喝了一杯
and they were charging a cover because it was open mic night and he put his name down just so he could get in and they called him and he had a few and he went up and just started doing stand up. And then it was quite cathartic and he started going back and he didn't tell anybody. And that's how he got into stand up.
他们刘取了入场费，因为那是开放式逐节之夜，他投了自己的名字仅仅是为了能进去，然后他们叫到了他的名字，他喝了一点酒，上台开始做站立喜剧。然后这很有发泄作用，他开始回去而且他没有告诉任何人。这就是他是怎么进入站立喜剧行列的。
Will, did you ever discuss doing it as him and doing the whole Liverpool accent and anything? Not really, because we didn't want it to be too much, too like Billy Elliot or Full Monty, you know what I mean? All due respect to those movies. We just wanted to tell a difference. So we set it in New York, Steven, and I wrote it with an Englishman with Mark Chappell
威尔，你们有没有讨论过让他用他的本色出演，带上整个利物浦口音什么的？其实没有，因为我们不想让它显得太过头，太像《跳出我天地》或《光猪六壮士》，你知道我的意思吗？对那些电影致以崇高的敬意。我们只是想讲述一个不同的故事。所以我们将背景设定在纽约，史蒂芬，我和一个英国人马克·查佩尔一起写了剧本
and Bradley Cooper directed, and Bradley's in it with me as well, yeah. Will, do you think you could do a Liverpool accent? Yeah, you can. No, it's tough. It's a tricky one, it is quite tricky, Jay. Yeah, because you hear him say, it's a tricky one. Like, there's a kind of like, almost like an in-hand. See, but then he sounds a little bit like Miss Doubtfire there.
布莱德利·库珀导演的，布莱德利也和我一起演，对的。威尔，你觉得你能说利物浦口音吗？行啊，你可以的。不，这很难。这是一个棘手的口音，确实挺棘手的，杰伊。对，因为你听他说，这挺棘手的。就那种感觉，差不多就像是手拿把攥的那种。看，但这么一说他听起来有点像道·费尔夫人了。
It's a tricky one, children, let's come down. No, we don't speak like that. It's a very difficult accent. That's why I just kind of, I leave it alone that one. It sounds like there's a little bit of Scottish in there. Is Liverpool North? Yes. Yeah, it is, and it's kind of,
这是一个棘手的问题，孩子们，我们冷静点。不，我们不那样说话。这是一个非常难的口音。这就是为什么我基本上不去碰它的原因。听起来里面有一点苏格兰口音。利物浦在北方吗？是的。对，是的，它有点像，
I think it's an amalgamation of Irish, Scottish, but also kind of because of the docks and the pollution, it's kind of to do with nasal and throat kind of extractions or whatever, do you know what I mean? Will's got that down. There's a science behind it. There's a, there are a lot of Irish people who immigrated to Liverpool.
我认为它是爱尔兰语、苏格兰语的混合体，但同时也是因为码头和污染，这有点类似于鼻腔和咽喉的发音或者别的什么，你知道我的意思吗？威利很擅长这个。这背后是有科学依据的。有很多爱尔兰人移民到了利物浦。
Yeah. Yeah, because it sounds a little bit Irish. Well, a lot of Scousers, I say Scousers, Scousers are just lazy Irish that couldn't be arsed going to America. When the boat came, they just stayed at Liverpool and didn't move forward, do you know what I mean? So, it's kind of...
对。对，因为听起来有点像爱尔兰口音。嗯，很多利物浦人——我说的是利物浦人，利物浦人就像是懒得去美国的爱尔兰人。当年船开来的时候，他们就呆在利物浦没再往前走，你知道我的意思吗？所以，这有点像……
Now the fellas in the Beatles, did they have famously thick Liverpool accents? But back then the accents were slightly different. Really? And obviously it's changed, but they, yeah, all of them, Paul, Ringo, Leo and George, obviously, they all have that Liverpool accent, but theirs was a lot more kind of singy at the time,
现在披头士乐队的这几个小伙子，他们是不是以浓重的利物浦口音而闻名？但那时候的口音略有不同。真的吗？显然现在已经变了，但他们，是的，所有这些人，保罗、林戈、利奥和乔治，显然，他们都有那种利物浦口音，但当时他们的口音听起来更有那种歌唱般的韵味，
do you know what I mean? It was more like that. It was more melodical and like nice little notes and things. That's the go-to when anybody does an impression of a Liverpool. So wait, so growing up there, what was your window to wanna be an actor when you were break dancing?
你知道我的意思吗？更像是那种感觉。更有旋律感，就像一些很好听的小音符之类的。当任何人模仿利物浦口音时，这都是首选的梗。所以等等，在那里长大时，当你还在跳霹雳舞的时候，是什么促使你想成为一名演员？
You're like, wait, if I'm not a break dancer, I'm going to be a... For me, it was really interesting because when I was about, I think, 11, we were doing a play in school. And across the road from my nana's house, a wonderful man called Drew Schofield lived there, and he was an actor, and he was on television,
你就像是在想，等等，如果我不是个霹雳舞者，我要成为一个……对我来说，这真的很有趣，因为当我大约11岁的时候，我们在学校里排练一场戏剧。在我奶奶家马路对面，住着一位名叫德鲁·斯科菲尔德的了不起的人，他是一名演员，经常上电视，
and he was on a show called Scully which was really popular and that was about a young man who had this dream and this fantasy of playing for Liverpool and he was the lead role in that and he lived across the road from my nana's house and no one in my family was ever into the arts or anything like that. Me and my dad used to go to the gallery and stuff like that and everything, and heavily into films. My dad got me right into films when I was a young lad, but no one had done anything like that.
他当时出演了一部名叫《斯库利》的电视剧，非常受欢迎，讲的是一个年轻小伙子梦想并幻想为利物浦效力的故事，他在里面扮演主角，就住在我奶奶家马路对面。我们家从来没有人从事艺术或类似的工作。我和我爸爸经常去美术馆之类的，而且非常喜欢电影。我爸爸在我很小的时候就把我领进了电影的大门，但从来没有人做过类似演艺这样的事情。
But I could see Drew across the road, and he was on the telly every week, so it made me realize that it was a possibility. And he came to watch a play we did in school. His nephew was in the same play, and at the end of it he said to my mum and dad, he said, look, I think Steven's really talented. You should look at maybe taking him
但我能看到德鲁在马路对面，他每周都上电视，这让我意识到这是一种可能。他来看了我们在学校演的一部话剧。他的侄子也演了同一部话剧，演完后他对我的爸爸妈妈说，你看，我觉得史蒂文真的很有天赋。你们也许应该考虑带他去
to a youth theater or something. And thank God, you know what I mean? I did, I went to the Everyman Youth Theater and that's kind of where it all started. How about that? Did you ever think along the way in high school, maybe I should do my studies in such a way where I can get into a college
去青年剧院之类的。谢天谢地，你知道我的意思吗？我去了，我加入了埃弗里曼青年剧院，一切就是从那里开始的。觉得怎么样？你在高中时有没有想过，也许我应该调整学习方式，以便能考上大学
and maybe study up on another career. Was there ever a backup? There wasn't, but there was also that kind of, I went to, my intention was to go to university and you know, if I couldn't make it as an actor, but give it a go, then I would hopefully fall into being a teacher. That was kind of the other role I was looking at
也许研究一下别的职业。曾经有过备用计划吗？没有，但也有一种情况，我去上大学的打算是，你知道的，如果我做不成演员，但尝试过了，我希望自己能顺理成章地成为一名教师。那是我当时考虑的另一种角色。
and the other way of going. Really? Like an elementary teacher that teaches all subjects or specializing in one in high school or college? Teaching drama in like a high school, do you know what I mean? Because over here we have GCSEs and stuff and that kind of, so that's secondary school.
还有另一种走法。真的吗？就像一个教所有科目的小学老师，还是在高中或大学专攻一门？比如在高中教戏剧，你知道我的意思吗？因为我们这边有GCSE之类的考试，所以那是中学。
Being a drama teacher, that was another possibility that I looked at. Or if not, believe it or not, I wanted to be a fireman. Yeah. Sure, why not? Same. Now wait, but this is pretty wild. Like I had no idea.
做一名戏剧老师，那是我考虑过的另一种可能性。或者如果不是的话，信不信由你，我想当一名消防员。是啊。当然，为什么不呢？一样。等等，但这太疯狂了。就像我完全不知道一样。
Be with a fireman? Yeah, be with a fireman. What did you say? No, no, it's a fireman and village people, that kind. Yeah, that's right. I keep forgetting that's what it is. Wait, your dad, your biological dad was Jamaican. And your-
跟消防员在一起？对，跟消防员在一起。你刚才说什么？不，不，那是消防员和乡村村民组合那种。对，没错。我总是忘那是怎么回事。等等，你爸爸，你的亲生父亲是牙买加人。而你的——
My granddad was from Jamaica, yeah. And your stepdad, African American? Yes, yes, Pops. That's awesome. Pops family. Yeah, Pops was being there since I was 10, so he's the man that's raised me, he's my father. And did you ever talk to your biological dad? I mean, when he was- Yeah, yeah, we haven't spoken for a me. He's my father. And did you ever talk to your biological dad? I mean, when he was...
我爷爷来自牙买加，是的。你的继父是非裔美国人？是的，是的，老爸。太棒了。老爸的家人。是的，老爸从我10岁起就在我身边，所以他是抚养我长大的人，他是我的父亲。你跟你亲生父亲聊过吗？我的意思是，当他——是的，是的，我们已经很久没说话了。他是我的父亲。你跟你亲生父亲聊过吗？我的意思是，当他——
Yeah, yeah, we haven't spoken for a while. There's no animosity there. I suppose kind of through that. But he didn't... Sean, are you familiar with this area? Yes, yes. Oh, God, hang on, I gotta get that. Hey, dad calling.
对，对，我们有一段时间没说话了。那里没有什么敌意。我想是通过那种方式吧。但他没有……肖恩，你对这一带熟悉吗？熟悉，熟悉。哦，天哪，等等，我得接个电话。嘿，我爸打来的。
One second. Can you hear me? Hello? Sometimes you grow apart, don't you? You know what I mean, in many ways. Yeah, oh yeah, sometimes you just drive away. Yeah, yeah, exactly. That's the running joke, Stephen,
等一下。你能听到我吗？喂？有时候你们会渐行渐远，对吧？你知道我的意思，在很多方面。是的，哦是的，有时候你只是开车离开。是的，这就是那个一直以来的笑话，斯蒂芬，
that my dad left when I was five. Anyway, so, okay, so, and you have siblings. And then did he really leave when he was five? Oh yeah, he spun the wheels. He just threw it and drive, and there was a screech. They didn't see any warning signs, I mean, other than he bought a sports car, a two-seater sports car with five kids.
我五岁时爸爸就离开了。不管怎样，所以，好吧，所以，你还有兄弟姐妹。然后他真的是在五岁时离开的吗？哦，对，他打方向盘转了弯。他直接挂挡开走，发出了刺耳的刹车声。他们没看到任何征兆，我的意思是，除了他买了辆跑车，一辆只有两个座位的跑车，而他有五个孩子。
No, no, no, wait a minute, let's be serious for a second. Did he just say, I'm just going to go to the shop, I'll be back in a minute. Yeah, I want to get some milk. No, he was in a Korean War, and he came back and he married my mom. A Korean War or the Korean War? The Korean War. Sorry. Okay. It was just mom. A Korean War or the Korean War?
不，不，不，等一下，我们认真一点。他刚才是不是说，我就去个店里，一会儿就回来。对，我想去买点奶。不，他参加过韩战，然后他回来娶了我妈。一场韩战还是朝鲜折战？朝鲜折战。对不起。好的。只是妈。一场韩战还是朝鲜折战？
The Korean War. Sorry. Okay. It was just one of them. He was in the army. And then he came back and he married my mom and had five kids and said, this isn't for me. Back to Korea?
朝鲜战争。抱歉。好吧。这只是其中之一。他在军队里。然后他回来了，娶了我妈妈，生了五个孩子，然后说，这不适合我。回朝鲜吗？
Yeah, no, I don't know where. I don't know. This isn't for me. I'd rather be back in a war theater than be part of this. Shit. So we, hang on, so five. Yeah. And then he made the decision to fuck off.
是啊，不，我不知道在哪。我不知道。这不适合我。我宁愿回到战区也不愿参与这破事。所以我们，等等，所以五个。对。然后他做出了滚蛋的决定。
Yeah. Wow. Look, Steve and I... Selfish bastard. If you spend a lot of time with Sean, it'll make sense. Yeah. No, wait, Sean, what number are you within that five? Five.
是啊。哇。你看，史蒂夫和我……自私的混蛋。如果你花很多时间和肖恩在一起，你就会明白了。是啊。不，等等，肖恩，在那五个人里你排第几？第五。
What? What number are you within that five? Are you the... Oh, I'm the youngest, I'm the youngest. Yeah, he's the one that really sealed the deal. Fuck me, well he stayed for the first four, Sean. Yeah, you were the one, I'm sorry. The four of kids.
什么？在这五个里面你排第几？你是……哦，我是最小的，我是最小的。对，他才是真正把这个组合锁定的人。操，他好歹还熬过了前四个呢，肖恩。对，你才是那个，我很抱歉。那四个孩子。
The bang on the money there. I mean, he put up with four and he was around. As soon as you came, it was like, get the fuck out of here. Sean, do you think it was the break dancing? Do you think that was the final? Maybe, maybe. I ain't raising any kid that does that.
真是一针见血。我是说，他忍受了四个，而且他一直都在。你一来，就像是：滚开这里。肖恩，你觉得是街舞吗？你觉得那是最后一根稻草吗？也许吧，也许吧。我可不养会那种东西的孩子。
Sean, you really were the straw that brought the camel back, weren't you? I really was. You get a lot of therapy now though, Sean. Oh God, I love it. Totally, I love it. Yeah, you know what, I got to say, of all the jokes that we do about it, Sean is so in front of this trauma, if you will, in a way that you talk about it in such a very healthy way, which is why we do joke about it. For our listener, because sometimes people are like,
肖恩，你真的是压死骆驼的最后一根稻草，对吧？我真的是。不过肖恩，你现在做了很多心理治疗。哦天哪，我太喜欢了。完全是，我太喜欢了。是的，你知道吗，我不得不说，在我们开的所有玩笑中，肖恩对这段创伤可以说是直面迎上的，你谈论它的方式非常健康，这就是为什么我们拿它开玩笑。为了我们的听众，因为有时人们会觉得，
man, you guys are really rough on Sean. No, I mean, the way that we deal with stuff, all of us, is by laughing about it. Yeah, totally. And it's earned laughter because you've been through all the processing and all the therapy, and now you've landed in the laughter. And I don't know, see, I grew up Irish Catholic,
天哪，你们对肖恩可真够苛刻的。不，我的意思是，我们所有人处理事情的方式，都是通过取笑它。是的，完全是这样。而且这种笑是应得的，因为你们已经经历了所有的心理疏导和治疗，现在你们终于释怀而笑了。而且我不知道，你看，我是爱尔兰天主教家庭长大的，
so we stuffed everything. So my therapy is to talk about the shit that I wasn't allowed to talk about when I was a kid. Exactly. And so it feels good to do it. That's why I talk about my mom's fake eye. Anyway, we're going on. Yeah, Stephen, yeah, so we can move over to the mother now
所以我们把所有情绪都压抑在心底。所以我的治疗方式就是谈论那些我小时候不被允许谈论的破事。完全正确。所以这样做感觉很好。这就是为什么我要谈论我妈妈的假眼。总之，我们继续吧。是的，斯蒂芬，对的，所以我们可以转到母亲这个话题了
with just the fake eyeball. Yeah, yeah, ad nauseam, we talked about ad nauseam. Stephen just was like, what? We brought his sister, we were on tour, and his sister brought the eyeball out on stage and opened it in a box and stuff, and we took it out. It was a lot of fun. Steve doesn't know whether we're kidding or not.
就拿着那个假眼球。对，对，反复地念叨，我们翻来覆去地念叨。斯蒂芬当时的反应就是，什么？我们把他妹妹带来了，我们在巡演，他妹妹把眼球带到了台上，在一个盒子里打开了之类的，我们把它拿了出来。这真的很有趣。史蒂夫根本分不清我们是在开玩笑还是认真的。
It's true. It's true. So your mom had a fake eyeball? Yeah, we were never allowed to ask about it. Except when she threw it. It was a glass eye then? Yeah, it was a glass eye. Yeah, yeah, yeah. How did she lose it? Nobody knows, she still can ask about it. Except when she threw it. It was a glass eye then? Yeah, it was a glass eye.
真的。真的。所以你妈妈有一只假眼球？对，我们从来不敢问。除非她把它扔出来。那那时候是玻璃眼球吗？对，是玻璃眼球。对，对，对。她是怎么失去这只眼睛的？没人知道，直到现在也不能问她。除非她把它扔出来。那那时候是玻璃眼球吗？对，是玻璃眼球。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. How did she lose it? Nobody knows, she still can't find it. No. She had cancer when she was two years old and so they had to take her eyeball out. Anyway, it's a hilarious story. Is your mom still alive?
对，对，对。她是怎么弄丢的？没人知道，她到现在还没找到。没有。她两岁的时候得了癌症，所以他们不得不把她的眼球摘除。总之，这是一个搞笑的故事。你妈妈还活着吗？
Nobody knows again. No, she passed away. No, but the eye is. No, she passed away, oh God, six years ago, maybe seven years ago. Anyway, I want to talk about. The irony that you don't remember in that she. Well, I know she, it was January of 2021, no, 2019 maybe.
没有人再知道了。不，她去世了。不，但是眼睛是。不，她去世了，天哪，六年前，也许七年前。总之，我想谈谈。你竟然不记得这个讽刺意味，而她……嗯，我知道她，那是2021年1月，不对，可能是2019年。
Yeah. Yeah. But look how well balanced you are. Look at you. Whatever it is, it's a nice young boy. No, no. I mean it. The way that you talk about it,
是的。是的。但看看你平衡得有多好。看看你。不管是什么，这都是个不错的年轻男孩。不，不。我是认真的。你谈论它的方式，
that you're so open about it and that you have come out the other side, as JB said, and done all the work, it is very healthy. Well, thank you. To be honest, it is inspiring. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
你对此如此坦诚，而且就像JB所说的那样，你已经走出了阴霾，完成了所有的努力，这非常健康。嗯，谢谢你。老实说，这很鼓舞人心。我们马上回来。现在，让我们回到节目中。
Wait, so you had brothers and sisters growing up, yes? And were they interested in what you did or no? Not really, no. They don't do anything near what you do? My life's very complicated because with that biological father, similar to yours, he went off and he had four children to four different women. Wow, wow.
等一下，所以你长大的时候有兄弟姐妹，对吧？他们对你做的事感兴趣吗？其实没有，并不感兴趣。他们做的事跟你完全不一样吗？我的生活非常复杂，因为那个亲生父亲，跟你的一样，他后来又跟四个不同的女人生了四个孩子。哇，哇。
So, yeah. But you know, look, everyone, he stood on his own. I'm all right now, I'm on the other side of it. Are you an only child from? No, I'm not, because my mom and pops, they had Nathan, who, there's a 20 year gap between me and Nathan. Older or younger?
所以，是的。但你知道的，听着，大家，他有他自己的立场。我现在没事了，我已经挺过来了。你是独生子女吗？不，我不是，因为我爸妈生了内森，我和内森之间有20岁的年龄差。大的还是小的？
He's my little brother. I'm 20 years older than him. My mom had me when she was 20 and she had our kid when she was 40. So the beauty of that though is I had all my time with my mom, who, God bless her soul, I adored, and all that time with pops who, you know,
他是我的小弟弟。我比他大20岁。我妈妈20岁时生了我，40岁时生了我们这个孩子。但其中的美好之处在于，我和我妈妈度过了所有的时光，愿上帝保佑她的灵魂，我崇拜她，还有和老爸在一起的所有时光，你知道的，
I loved to bits who raised me. Like I said, you know, he taught me about my history, Marcus Garvey, Malcolm X, Toussaint Louberture, all of those things about my historical background and where my origins are from. So I was given all of that beautiful information by him. So I was always educated in that respect. And then when I was ready to leave
我极其深爱抚养我长大的那个人。就像我说的，你知道，他教导我了解我的历史，马库斯·加维、马尔科姆·X、杜桑·卢维图尔，所有这些关于我的历史背景以及我的根源所在的事情。所以我从他那里获得了所有这些美好的信息。因此我在那方面一直受过良好的教育。然后当我准备离开时
to go to university at the age of 20, Nathan was born. So we never had any of that sibling rivalry. And I love our Nathan to bits. Technically, look, he could have been my dad, who's there for my kids massively. I love that expression, our Nathan, that you get, like my friend who grew up in sort of the West Country, they say like, our Mark. Yeah.
到20岁上大学时，内森出生了。所以我们从来没有那种兄弟姐妹间的竞争。我非常爱我们的内森。从技术上讲，你看，他本可以当我爸，他非常疼爱我的孩子们。我很喜欢“我们的内森”这种表达，就像我那个在英格兰西南部长大的朋友，他们会说“我们的马克”。是的。
I love that, there's something really endearing about it. Indeed, and quality. Just sort of the inclusiveness of it, and you know, it's... Sweet. I mean, my dad's... Sorry, just to pick up on that point as well, when I was about 14, and I said, I think pick up on that point as well, when I was about 14 and I said,
我太喜欢了，这其中有一种真的很讨人喜欢的感觉。确实，还有质量。那种包容性，你知道，这很……甜蜜。我是说，我爸爸……抱歉，顺便补充一下那个观点，当我大概14岁的时候，我说，我想顺便补充一下那个观点，当我大概14岁的时候，我说，
I think I really want to be an actor, dad was like, all right, come on, let's go. I was like, what? It was before Blockbuster even. This was just a local video shop, just a little independent ones. We went in and we looked and he picked these three films. And it was, he picked The Deer Hunter, The Godfather, and Taxi Driver. And then we went home and he was like, right, we're going to watch these.
我想我真的很想成为一名演员，我爸就说，好吧，来吧，我们走。我说，什么？那甚至还在百视通出现之前。这只是一家本地的视频店，一家很小的独立店面。我们走进去看了看，他挑选了三部电影。分别是《猎鹿人》、《教父》和《出租车司机》。然后我们回家了，他说，好了，我们要把这些看完。
This is how you do it properly. Let's watch these films. And we spent the whole weekend rewatching those three films. Which is your favorite from those three? That's a tricky one, isn't it? I love the deer hunter. I love the deer hunter. And then when you were in your 20s, you were in gang, like 14 years old, you said you wanted
这才是正确的方法。让我们看这些电影。我们花整个周末重温了那三部电影。在这三部中你最喜欢哪一部？这挺棘手的，对吧？我喜欢《猎鹿人》。我喜欢《猎鹿人》。然后当你二十多岁的时候，你加入了帮派，大约14岁的时候，你说你想
to be in the six years later, you're Gangs of New York with Martin Scorsese. I mean, that's crazy. That was so fast. It was another incredible film. Quite mind-blowing as well to be a part of. What was that like from the moment that you knew that it was a project that was happening to getting an audition to being there?
六年后，你就能和马丁·斯科塞斯一起合作《纽约黑帮》了。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。进展太快了。这也是另一部不可思议的电影。能参与其中也让人大开眼界。从得知这个项目正在筹备到去试镜，再到加入剧组，那是一种怎样的体验？
Can you comment on that? It was... I got the call from my agent and said, to being there? I got the call from my agent and said, we need you to come in and do a read and put yourself on tape. I met Ellen Lewis, who's wonderful. We just had a really lovely time and I read these couple of scenes and then I went away. And it was one of them, you know, where you don't hear for like four or five weeks later and you kind of go, I told you there's no chance. So as a job and actor
你能对此发表一下看法吗？当时是……我接到经纪人的电话，然后……从去那里开始？我接到经纪人的电话，说我们需要你来读一下剧本并录像。我遇到了艾伦·刘易斯，她太棒了。我们度过了一段非常美好的时光，我读了这几场戏，然后就离开了。那是那种你懂的，大概有四五周都没有任何消息，然后你心里就会想，我早就说过根本没机会。所以作为一份工作和演员
and a young lad, I had to go for this, we've all done it, that's, let's be honest, I had to go for this bag of shit audition. I really didn't want to go. It was fucking awful. But I'm on the train, I'm sweating, I'm on my way into London, you know, you got to pay the rent, haven't you got to eat? So I'm there and I'm like, and I'm going through this fucking awful script and I'm like, okay, all right, yeah, having a coffee. And then the next minute my phone goes,
当我还是个小伙子的时候，我不得不去参加这个——我们都做过，说实话，我不得不去参加这个烂透了的试镜。我真的很不想去。这太他妈糟糕了。但我坐在火车上，我在流汗，我在去伦敦的路上，你知道的，你得付房租，你不是得吃饭吗？所以我坐在那儿，然后我一边看着这本他妈的糟糕剧本，一边想，好吧，好吧，是的，喝着咖啡。然后下一刻我的电话响了，
and it was my agent, Jane, and she said to him, she said, are you sitting down? I was like, yeah, I'm sitting down. She went, right, okay, you've got that part in Gangs of New York. I was like, what? She went, yeah, they came back today, you've got a flight to, you've got a flight to Italy.
那是我的经纪人简，她对他说，她问，你坐着吗？我当时想，对，我坐着。她说，好吧，你拿下了《纽约黑帮》里的那个角色。我当时想，什么？她说，对，他们今天回复了，你有一张去……你有一张去意大利的机票。
I'd say this was Friday, you've got a flight to Italy on Monday. Marty wants to sit down and talk to you and go through the character. And I was like, what? And I was made up. Oh, God. But then the best bit was I went,
我想这是周五，你周一就要飞往意大利了。马蒂想跟你坐下来谈谈，顺便顺一遍角色。我当时就想，什么？我当时高兴坏了。哦，天哪。但最棒的部分是，我去了，
does that mean I don't have to go for this audition now? Yeah. No, you don't have to go for that. I was like, thank you, fuck that. And so then I flew out there and we met and it was wonderful and it was just a wonderful experience. And that was when I became friends with Leo as well. That's when we got together.
这是否意味着我现在不用去参加这个试镜了？是的。不，你不用去参加那个了。当时我想，谢谢，去他的。然后我飞到那里，我们见面了，非常棒，那真是一段美好的经历。也就是在那时，我和莱昂也成了朋友。那是我们在一起的时候。
That's amazing. And there was some story about a golf cart or something? We were with a golf cart around the set? Yeah, I tipped the golf cart over and I nearly broke his leg, yeah. Oh, okay, okay. Oh, yeah. Yeah, you can get really messed up on those things.
太惊人了。还有关于高尔夫球车什么的传闻？我们开着高尔夫球车在片场转悠？对，我把高尔夫球车开翻了，差点把他的腿给弄断。哦，好吧，好吧。哦，对。是的，你真的会在那种东西上弄得很惨。
Yeah. Yeah. You don't realize they're dangerous. I think that if you go to my Wikipedia page and you look at my filmography, Steven, they all fall under the category of you have to pay the rent. For what it's worth. Okay. Well, and then this is wild.
是的。是的。你并没有意识到它们是危险的。我想如果你去我的维基百科页面看我的电影作品，史蒂芬，它们都属于“你得付房租”这一类。不管怎么说。好吧，然后这太疯狂了。
So one of the three movies you mentioned was The Godfather, and then you're with Pacino, you know, and the Irishman. Well, can you imagine that phone call to me, Dad? I mean, that's incredible. That's incredible. I had to go to, it was a wonderful, wonderful story. I was doing a little series over here called The Virtues with Shane Meadows, and it was a wonderful experience. And on the Friday, I had to fly to New York
所以你提到的三部电影之一是《教父》，然后你和帕西诺合作了，还有《爱尔兰人》。天哪，你能想象当时打给我的那个电话吗，爸爸？我的意思是，这太不可思议了。这太不可思议了。我不得不去，那是一个非常非常棒的故事。我当时在这里拍一部小系列剧，叫《美德》，导演是肖恩·米多斯，那是一次绝佳的经历。到了周五，我不得不飞往纽约
to go to Marty's house to meet Robert De Niro, because Rob was an exec and you had to meet him, and he wanted to make sure that I was right and things like that. So you can imagine how nervous I was, and I had to fly to New York. So I finished work, I think, first thing Monday, they let me go early, so I had to fly out, and then I got there. Literally, I had to land, go to Marty's house,
去马丁家见罗伯特·德尼罗，因为罗布是执行制片人，你必须去见他，而且他想确保我是合适的人选之类的。所以你可以想象我当时有多紧张，我不得不飞往纽约。所以我完成了工作，我想，周一头一件事，他们让我早点走，所以我不得不飞过去，然后我到了那里。实际上，我刚落地，就去了马丁家，
and see Marty, and then I met, I'm sitting there, and then Bob comes up, and he's got his little cap on, and he's got the paper underneath his arm, and a pair of shorts, and a little baggy shirt, and he's like, hey. And it was unbelievable, it was amazing. We had a wonderful afternoongy shirt. And he's like, hey. And it was unbelievable. It was amazing. We had a wonderful afternoon.
见到马蒂，然后我遇到了，我坐在那里，鲍勃走了过来，戴着他的小帽子，胳膊底下夹着报纸，穿着短裤和一件宽松的小衬衫，他说，嘿。这简直难以置信，太棒了。我们度过了一个美好的下午。
But Ellen had said to me, look, he doesn't really talk much. So I'm thinking, oh, shit. Yeah, yeah. She's like, so you might have to make some conversation. I'm like, OK. Anyway, cut to we were there for about 2 and 1 half hours. And then they went like, right, OK, you best go. And then I said, have I got the part?
但是艾伦之前对我说过，听着，他其实不太说话。所以我在想，哦，糟糕。对，对。她说，所以你可能得找点话题聊聊。我说，好吧。总之，镜头一转，我们在那儿呆了大约两个半小时。然后他们说，好啦，好吧，你最好走吧。接着我说，我得到这个角色了吗？
I went, I can't leave now without knowing if I've got the part. And then Bob was like, just give us a minute, go on. Just give us a minute. And I was like, oh shit, okay, I've tried my hardest. I don't know if this is going to work. I hope so, I don't know if he likes me. First of all, he was like, you're not Italian.
我去了，我现在不拿到角色结果就走不了。然后鲍勃就说，给我们一分钟，快去。就给我们一分钟。然后我就想，糟了，好吧，我已经尽力了。我不知道这行不行得通。希望可以吧，我不知道他喜不喜欢我。首先，他说，你不是意大利人。
I'm like, no, I'm not Italian. And so then I come back in and I sit down and he goes, sit down, sit down, I'll let Marty tell you. And then Marty was like, okay kid, so, do you want to do this? And I was like, of course. And then I got a hug off them and I felt like, you know in all the films, I felt like I was a made man,
我说，不，我不是意大利人。然后我走进去坐下，他说，坐下，坐下，我让马蒂告诉你。接着马蒂就说，好吧，孩子，那么，你想干这行吗？我说，当然想。然后我得到了他们的一个拥抱，我觉得，就像所有电影里演的那样，我感觉自己成了黑手党正式成员，
do you know what I mean? I feel made by the back of your boss. Or I'd be taken out the back and put two in the head. And then you can imagine that phone call to my dad and the pride gets me emotional. Just think about it a little bit. You know, I'm a young kid from a block of flats, a young mixed-race kid who had a dream to be an actor.
你知道我的意思吗？我觉得自己就像被你老板利用后抛弃了一样。或者我会带到后巷被枪决。然后你能想象打给我爸爸的那个电话，那种骄傲让我情绪激动。稍微想一想。你知道的，我只是一个来自普通公寓楼的年轻孩子，一个怀揣着演员梦想的年轻混血孩子。
And my dad took me to that video shop, like you say, Shaun, and in the next minute I'm phoning him up saying, I'm going to be in a film with Robert De Niro and Al Pacino and being directed by Martin Scorsese. So, you know. That's really cool. Oh man. It's one of those beautiful stories.
然后我爸爸带我去了那家录像带店，正如你所说的，肖恩，紧接着我给他打电话说，我要和罗伯特·德尼罗和阿尔·帕西诺一起拍电影，导演是马丁·斯科塞斯。所以呢，这真的很酷。天哪。这是一个美好的故事。
And Martin Scorsese is famous for many things. One of which though is his kindness and his warmth and his spirit on set. And you've had the chance to work with him at least twice. Three occasions. Three times, yeah. Wow. Yeah, good for you.
马丁·斯科塞斯因很多事情而闻名。其中之一就是他在片场展现出的善良、温暖和精神风貌。你有机会与他合作至少两次。三次机会。三次，是的。哇。是的，真为你高兴。
Yeah, it's really cool. It's an amazing, lovely one. And then when I met you, Steven, at the Graham Norton show just in February, and you were so, I mean, I just fucking loved you right away, you were so normal and kind, and like, it was just great. That's such a fun show.
对啊，真的很酷。这是一个非常棒、很可爱的节目。然后今年二月份我在格 Graham Norton 秀上遇到你的时候，史蒂芬，你真的——我是说，我一眼就超级喜欢你，你人太正常太友善了，感觉真的太棒了。那个节目太有趣了。
They should air that here. Steven, what did you think of Sean? I mean, he said that about you. And be honest, And be brutally honest. He was lovely. He was wonderful. He was like a ray of sunshine. Yeah.
他们应该在这里播这个。史蒂文，你觉得肖恩怎么样？我是说，他那样评价你。说实话，要极其坦诚。他很可爱。他太棒了。他就像一缕阳光。是啊。
Sean was a ray of sunshine. Yeah, he was lovely. Our Sean. Your Sean. Yeah, see? Look, see the endearment there? Your Sean was lovely. And really wonderful.
肖恩就像一束阳光。对，他很可爱。我们的肖恩。你的肖恩。对，你看？看到了吗，这里面带着爱意呢？你的肖恩很可爱。而且真的很棒。
You know what I mean? He was very gregarious. It was lovely. And afterwards I was like, oh my God, you gotta come on the show, so it's nice of you to. Yeah, he did, he asked me. But wait, you were promoting a movie
你知道我的意思吗？他非常合群。这太美妙了。后来我想，哦天哪，你一定要上这个节目，所以你能来真好。是的，他确实这么做了，他邀请了我。但是等等，你当时是在宣传一部电影
where you trained to be this boxer, and the movie's called A Thousand Blows. It was a TV series on Disney, A Thousand Blows, set in the 1800s, that was. And I haven't seen it yet, but those clips, I was like, that looks incredible. Oh, go ahead, A Thousand Blows. No, Sean, clips, I was like, that looks incredible. Oh, go ahead, a thousand blows. Go ahead, Will, what you got?
你在那里接受了拳击训练，这部电影叫《千拳之击》。这是迪士尼的一部电视剧，叫《千拳之击》，背景设定在19世纪。我还没看过，但那些片段，我觉得看起来太棒了。哦，请继续，《千拳之击》。不，肖恩，那些片段，我觉得看起来太棒了。哦，请继续，《千拳之击》。请继续，威尔，你有什么要说的？
No, Sean and Jason and I are just looking at each other on a thousand. Who's got the joke here? Who wants to go on a thousand blows? You haven't? I don't have it yet, I'm still writing it. Will, if you're there, go ahead. See, my missus went, as soon as he said, right, a thousand blows, my missus went,
不，肖恩、杰森和我只是在大眼瞪小眼。谁这里有好笑的？谁想来一千重击？你没有吗？我还没有，我还在写。威尔，如果你在的话，请说吧。看，我老婆一听到他说“好，一千重击”，我老婆就说，
sounds a bit like a top shelf. I mean, it's just, it's like, it's like, it's Sean, right? It's like my summer in, Sean Hayes, my summer in Meekano's. A thousand blows. So. My time's sure on Fire Island. I imagine it's different than that, Steven, yeah.
听起来有点像高端货。我的意思是，这就像，这就像肖恩一样，对吧？就像我在米科诺斯的夏天，肖恩·海耶斯，我在米科诺斯的夏天。千击。所以。我在火岛的时光肯定。我想这和那个不太一样，史蒂芬，是的。
The movie. Are you, did you train? Did you train as a fighter? Yes, I trained. Oh, sorry, you're asking him. Yeah, I did, yeah, yeah, I did. Yeah, I did, well, yeah, I did. Yeah, I did a lot of boxing, a shitload of protein,
这部电影。你，你训练过吗？你作为格斗手训练过吗？对，我训练过。哦，抱歉，你在问他。对，我训练过，对，对，我训练过。对，我训练过，嗯，对，我训练过。对，我练了很多拳击，吃了大量的蛋白质，
and yeah, it was great. I had six months when I got into the best shape I've ever been in. Yeah, I mean you're very young. I mean you're not 20, but you're still pretty young. I'm 51, yeah. Yeah, to do all that training at 51, that's crazy. Were you a boxing fan or are you a?
是的，太棒了。我有六个月的时间达到了我这辈子最好的状态。是的，我是说你非常年轻。我是说你不到20岁，但你还是很年轻。我51岁了，是的。是的，在51岁时进行所有这些训练，这太疯狂了。你以前是个拳击迷吗，还是你现在是？
Yeah, yeah, I've always been a boxing fan. And how do you feel about where boxing is now? Or have you transferred over to UFC or are you still a purist with the boxing? I like UFC. boxing is now, or have you transferred over to UFC, or are you still a purist with the boxing? I like UFC. I'm not 100% on the kind of, look, it's attracting audiences, I get that, I understand that.
对，对，我一直是个拳击迷。那你觉得现在拳击运动怎么样？还是说你已经转而看UFC了，或者你依然是个拳击纯粹主义者？我挺喜欢UFC的。现在的拳击，或者你已经转而看UFC了，或者你依然是个拳击纯粹主义者？我挺喜欢UFC的。我对那种……听着，它确实能吸引观众，这点我懂，我理解。
But I think it's gone a little bit sensationalist now. So brutal. I'm more of a fan of the pure art of pugilism, do you know what I mean, and the belts. And I feel like the belts are important, and to be number one in the world, or a world champion is an important thing to be. I'm going to say something that's maybe unpopular, which is that my problem with the MMA in general is that
但我认为现在它变得有点哗众取宠了。太残酷了。我更喜欢纯粹的拳击艺术，你知道我的意思吗，还有那些金腰带。我觉得金腰带很重要，成为世界第一，或者成为世界冠军是一件很重要的事。我要说一个可能不太受欢迎的观点，那就是我对综合格斗（MMA）总体的看法是，
there is a, to me anyway, there is a kind of a darkness around it, that I find, around the culture of it, that I find really... Almost a bloodlust. Yeah, there's something about it. that I find around the culture of it, that I find really... Yeah, there's something about it. Boxing you get that is sort of the purity of the sweet science, is that what they call it?
在我看来，它周围有一种……怎么说呢，有一种黑暗的氛围，我觉得，围绕着它的文化，让我觉得真的很……甚至有一种嗜血感。对，它确实有某种特质。围绕着它的文化，让我觉得真的很……对，它确实有某种特质。拳击你也能感受到那种“甜蜜科学”的纯粹，他们是这么叫的吗？
That's sort of the art of it. And of course there's a ton of art to MMA, and I'm not disparaging what the athletes do, but the culture around it, to me, there's the sort of the culture around it, to me there's a, I don't know, there's a sort of a darkness to it. Just me. I mean, starting with them doing it all in a cage.
那算是它的一种艺术。当然，MMA里也有大量的艺术成分，我不是在贬低运动员们的付出，但在我看来，它周围的文化……有一种，怎么说呢，有一种黑暗的氛围。只是我个人的感觉。我是说，从他们全都在一个笼子里打开始。
Yeah. Is the optics of it. But it's still, it's really fascinating. And it's the multiple disciplines. Exactly, the multiple disciplines. Inside that cage too. Oh, it's incredible. Which is kind of cool.
对。这就是视觉效果。但它仍然，真的很吸引人。而且它是多门学科的结合。没错，就是多门学科的结合。而且就在那个笼子里。哦，这太不可思议了。这其实挺酷的。
So yeah, I'm conflicted on it myself. And to me though, one of my favorites is Paddy the Baddy, who is also a Scouser. He's great, he's fantastic. Do you guys know this guy? He's so funny. Is he a boxer? He's an MMA fighter. He's an MMA fighter.
所以，是的，我对它也挺矛盾的。不过对我来说，我最喜欢的人之一是帕蒂·德巴迪（Paddy the Baddy），他也是个利物浦人。他很棒，太棒了。你们认识这家伙吗？他太逗了。他是拳击手吗？他是MMA选手。他是MMA选手。
He's so profoundly funny to me. Every time I see him, God, he's good. And he's tough as nails. Yeah, he's amazing. He's brutal, but he also doesn't take himself too seriously as well. And I love the kind of showmanship of that kind. Look, Ali was the best showman we ever had.
我觉得他太有幽默感了。每次我看到他，天哪，他太棒了。而且他强硬得要命。对，他太惊艳了。他很残暴，但他也很会自嘲，这一点我也很喜欢。我喜欢那种表演风格。听着，阿里是我们见过最会表演的人。
Yeah. But you know, he also, and you go, yeah, but Ali respected the other fighters. No, he didn't. No. If you listen to some of the things he used to say, especially to George Foreman, some of the things he said to him was, you No, he didn't. No. If you listen to some of the things he used to say, especially to George Foreman, some of the things he said to him was horrific.
对。但你知道的，他也会……你会说，对，但阿里尊重其他拳手。不，他才没有。没有。如果你听听他以前说过的一些话，尤其是对乔治·福尔曼说的那些话，他对他说的一些话，你……不，他才没有。没有。如果你听听他以前说过的一些话，尤其是对乔治·福尔曼说的那些话，他对他说的一些话简直骇人听闻。
And Patti the Batty, he uses that thing that you guys, the Scousers do of calling everybody lad and putting lad in everywhere. And there's something sort of hilariously disparaging when you use the term lad, yeah? Yeah, yeah, I know what you mean. Have a look at him, Jay. Some of his videos, he's really funny as well.
至于帕蒂·德巴迪，他用了你们利物浦人那种称呼方式，管谁都叫“小子（lad）”，到处都带上“小子”。当你用“小子”这个词时，有一种搞笑的贬义，对吧？对，对，我懂你的意思。杰伊，去看看他的视频。他的一些视频也真的很好笑。
He's very sharp. What weight class is he? I'm not too sure, it might be light weight. Oh yeah? Yeah. All your tattoos, did you just not cover them up? No, I did, yeah. That was, you spend like 50 minutes in a chair getting painted
他脑子转得很快。他是哪个级别的？我不太确定，可能是轻量级。是吗？对。你身上的那些纹身，你没把它们遮盖起来吗？没有，我遮了。那次，你在椅子上让人画了大概50分钟
when we did the thing, yeah. And then they don't come off in the shower, the cover up. Yeah, it's gonna be. Really. And you have a tattoo of your nanny, or for your nanny or something? And I never heard this term, a fairy cake.
我们拍那个的时候，对。然后那些遮盖的妆在淋浴时洗不掉。对，就是那样。真的吗。你身上是不是有个你保姆的纹身，或者是为了纪念你保姆什么的？我从来没听过“仙女蛋糕（fairy cake）”这个词。
We just call it a cupcake. Yeah, no, my nanny, she used to, when we were kids, she used to make fairy cakes. Yeah, cupcakes. Cupcakes, okay. Yeah, fairies. Nothing on fairy cake, Will, no? I'm sorry, did you beat, no.
我们只叫它杯子蛋糕（cupcake）。对，没有啦，我保姆，我们小时候，她经常做仙女蛋糕。对，杯子蛋糕。杯子蛋糕，好吧。对，仙女。对仙女蛋糕没意见吧，威尔？不好意思，你刚才是不是……没有。
No? I'll give you a couple more minutes, go ahead. Continue with the interview. I never heard that before, I never heard fairy cake. No, no, no, obviously not a lot of Americans have. Hey, fairy cakes, did you? So then what is your, when you're not doing these incredible projects, Steven,
没有？我再给你几分钟，你接着说。继续你的采访。我以前从没听过这个词，从没听过仙女蛋糕。不，不，不，显然很多美国人没听过。嘿，仙女蛋糕，你听过吗？那么，当你不在进行这些不可思议的项目时，斯蒂芬，
what is something, what is your primary hobby? I bet it's not boxing. What is something that occupies your time that people might be surprised about? Oh, meditation. Yes? Right? Meditation.
你的主要爱好是什么？我敢打赌肯定不是拳击。有什么事情占用了你的时间，可能会让人感到意外？哦，冥想。是吗？真的吗？冥想。
I love that. I'm constantly trying to learn how to do that without falling asleep. That's the key. It's right on the edge. No, just bang on the door and you may laugh, but that's the key, yeah. The key is not to fall asleep.
我太喜欢这个了。我一直在努力学习如何在不睡着的情况下做到这一点。这才是关键。就在那个边缘。不，简直一语中的，你可能会笑，但这就是关键，对。关键是不能睡着。
There's a wonderful practitioner called Mugee. If you get a chance, go on YouTube, I'm a little type of Mugee and have a listen to him. His voice is fantastic, but his pointings and his teachings are wonderful. And he always says, you know, look, the basic aim is to try and not to fall asleep in many ways with meditation.
有一个非常棒的修行者叫慕吉（Muji）。如果有机会，去YouTube上搜一下，搜一下“慕吉”，听听他的讲法。他的声音太棒了，而且他的指引和教导非常精彩。他总是说，你看，冥想的一个基本目标在很多方面其实就是尽量不睡着。
But in the same, because that's, but if you think about it, when the head shuts off, most of the time is when you're asleep. You know, that's when the subconscious comes into effect. But predominantly it's that kind of trying to stop the white noise and that constant pounding of the head to step out, but it's just allowing it to, oh, where have I gone?
但同时，因为那……但如果你想想看，大脑关机大部分时间都是在你睡着的时候。你知道的，那是潜意识发挥作用的时候。但主要还是那种试图停止杂音、停止大脑不断敲击的努力，去抽离出来，但它只是顺其自然，哦，我飘到哪儿去了？
Yeah, it's just allowing it to be. Oh, it's good, I want to do it. It's trying to get your brain to think about nothing. Nothing, right? But then that's the key, we'll see. Sorry, Jason, that's the key, isn't it? We're trying to get the brain to think about nothing, and in that trying, you're already doing.
对，就是顺其自然。哦，这太好了，我也想试试。这就是试图让你的大脑什么都不想。什么都不想，对吧？但这就是关键，我们看吧。抱歉，杰森，这就是关键，对吧？我们试图让大脑什么都不想，而在这种努力的过程中，你其实已经在做了。
So it's that kind of just letting the clouds pass. Yeah, I love that. Do you know what else I've got into, if you thought, So it's that kind of letting the clouds pass. Do you know what else I've got into? Ice baths, but not in an egotistical sense. If you do two minutes, it does everything your body needs. I've been doing it for 10 years and it's been a game changer for me, man, absolute game changer. And it is, that is, I wish I could meditate like JB, I've thought about it, I've sort of,
所以这就有点像让云彩飘过。对，我太喜欢这个了。你知道我最近还迷上了什么吗，如果你觉得……所以这就有点像让云彩飘过。你知道我最近还迷上了什么吗？冷水浴，但不是出于什么自我炫耀的心态。如果你泡两分钟，它就能满足你身体所需的一切。我已经坚持10年了，这对我来说简直是个转折点，兄弟，绝对的转折点。而且确实如此，那就是……我真希望自己能像JB那样冥想，我想过，我曾……
I've gotten apps before and I've tried it and I've had, and I remember somebody saying to me once, like imagine a stream and leaves are falling off the stream and each thought is like a leaf, and then just let it go with it a little bit and then you can just reset back under the thing. I just started doing it and- Right, and it does work, but I do it in the cold.
我以前下载过APP尝试过，而且我记得有人曾对我说过，想象一条小溪，树叶从溪流中落下，每一个想法就像一片叶子，然后顺着它稍微流走，接着你就能重新回到那个状态。我刚开始尝试的时候——对，这确实有用，但我是泡在冷水里做的。
I do, I get in that thing where I just, I'm like, I'm going to do three minutes and I just think about my breathing, think about my breathing and then yeah. When I first started doing, when I first started meditating, this is, I'm talking about like a month ago, like really doing it.
我就是这样，我会进入那种状态，心想：我要坚持三分钟，然后我只关注我的呼吸，关注我的呼吸，然后就这样。我刚开始做的时候，刚开始冥想的时候，我是说，大概一个月前，真正开始做的时候。
I started, every single time I would do it, I'd start to cry because my brain works overtime constantly from the moment I wake up to the moment I go to bed. I'm constantly thinking about it, and it's going 80 miles an hour from anxiety, whatever. And then, so I didn't, and sugar, and I didn't know what to do with myself when I'm still. So I would just start welling up and I was like,
我刚开始时，每次一做就会开始哭，因为我的大脑从醒来到入睡都在不停地超负荷运转。我一直在胡思乱想，由于焦虑什么的，大脑在以每小时80英里的速度运转。然后，因为我不知道在安静下来时该拿自己怎么办。所以我就会开始眼眶湿润，然后我想……
but now I'm not anymore, that's good. That's it. Oh yeah, you seem fixed for sure. Yeah. You nailed it. But it is, it's that look, you can be mindful with anything you do. You don't have to, the art of it itself is the art.
但现在我不会了，这很好。就是这样。哦，对，你看起来确实调整好了。对。你做到了。但确实如此，你看，你在做任何事时都可以保持正念。你不需要……艺术本身就是艺术。
The practices become the art, you know what I mean? At least you're taking that time. You also might be out of tears, Sean. Might just be. It's true. Rebuilding the well. This is true. But there is that thing of also like,
练习本身就成了艺术，你知道我的意思吗？至少你花了这个时间。肖恩，可能也是因为你眼泪流干了吧。有可能。正在重建泪腺。确实如此。但还有那种感觉，就是……
when you're doing it and then you hear like you isolate the sound of the refrigerator running or whatever and that's okay. Then think about that, then focus on that, then allow those things and it's just the allowing, it's the constant. And then when you're done with the meditation, you really do feel calmer and more focused and present. I mean it sounds like-
当你正在冥想时，然后你听到，比如你分理出了冰箱运转的声音或别的什么声音，那没关系。那就去想那个，专注于那个，然后接纳这些声音，关键就是接纳，持续地接纳。然后当你完成冥想时，你真的会感觉更平静、更专注、更活在当下。我的意思是听起来……
Have you ever tried TM? Steven, have you ever tried TM? I've wanted to do that. What is that? Oh, transcendental. What's the difference? Yeah, I don't really know, but I guess that that's a different,
你试过超觉冥想（TM）吗？斯蒂芬，你试过超觉冥想吗？我很想试试那个。那是什么？哦，超觉（Transcendental）。有什么区别？对，我其实不太清楚，但我猜那是另一种，
it's a different practice, the transcendental meditation. That was all that kind of David Lynch skill, wasn't it, and everything? Was it? Yeah, I think so. Stephen, we've taken up way too much of your time. Thank you for being here.
那是一种不同的修行方式，超觉冥想。那不都是大卫·林奇擅长的那些东西吗，诸如此类的？是吗？对，我想是的。斯蒂芬，我们占用了你太多时间了。谢谢你来到这里。
Not enough of your time. God, I could talk to you forever. I know, I love you. I agree. Where are you right now and what are you going to do the rest of the day? I am in New York. We got here on, yeah, we got here on Monday.
时间还远远不够。天哪，我可以跟你聊一我知道，我爱你。我同意。你现在在哪儿，今天剩下的时间打算做什么？我在纽约。我们是，对，我们是周一到这里的。
And then Seth Meyers, I think we're doing today, this afternoon. Yeah, sure. Right, later on. And then I'm going to go home. And to answer your question as well, Jason, my family is my favorite thing to do in the whole world. I feel very blessed and very, I'm very lucky
然后赛斯·迈尔斯（Seth Meyers）的节目，我想我们今天下午要去录。对，没错。稍后去。然后我就要回家了。回答你的问题，杰森，我的家人是我全世界最喜欢的事。我感到非常幸福，非常幸运，
and I'm full of gratitude that I have. I have the most amazing wife and two gorgeous kids. I love them to bits. Yeah, that's so great. I love that. Well, we love you. Thank you for being here, Steven. Yeah, it was so nice to see you.
并且充满感激之情。我有一个最棒的妻子和两个可爱的孩子。我爱死他们了。太棒了。我太喜欢这个了。好吧，我们爱你。谢谢你来到这里，斯蒂芬。对，很高兴见到你。
Huge fan. Huge fan of yours, man. Keep going, keep going. Thank you. All. Thank you, Steve. Big, big fan of yours. Huge fan of yours, Mattie. Keep going, keep going. Thank you. All right, my friend. Thanks for doing this. How do they say goodbye in Liverpool? I don't know.
超级粉丝。我是你的超级粉丝，老兄。继续加油，继续加油。谢谢。好啦，我的朋友。谢谢你参加节目。他们在利物浦是怎么说再见的？我不知道。
Ta-da. Ta-da? Ta-da. I never heard of that. Ta-da. Ta-da. Ta-da. Enjoy the rest of your day.
Ta-da。Ta-da？Ta-da。我从没听过这个。Ta-da。Ta-da。Ta-da。祝你接下来的一天过得愉快。
See you, bud. Take care, thank you. See you later. Bye, bye, bye. Bye. Sean, what a guest. I love him. When I met him at the Graham Norton Show,
回见，伙计。保重，谢谢。回头见。拜拜，拜拜，拜拜。拜拜。肖恩，真是个绝佳的嘉宾。我太喜欢他了。当我在格雷厄姆·诺顿秀（Graham Norton Show）上遇到他时，
I was like, oh, I totally know Stephen Graham. Like, I know his work. But you never know how anybody is. And I met him, we ended up just talking and talking, and I'm like, he's such a great human being. A nice spirit. Great vibe. Yeah, and so talented, and so many things that we all know.
我当时想，哦，我完全知道斯蒂芬·格雷厄姆是谁。我是说，我知道他的作品。但你永远不知道真人是什么样的。我遇到他后，我们俩就一直聊个不停，我想，他真的是个太棒的人了。灵魂很有趣。磁场很合。对，而且非常有才华，演过很多我们都知道的作品。
So many big movies and TV shows. Yeah, he's been a really high level character actor for a long, long time. You'd probably like, if you'd put one of your favorite movies on, you haven't watched for a while, you go, oh, there he is. There's Stephen Graham, yeah. Another great example, we were talking about recently,
很多大电影和电视剧。对，他长期以来一直是个非常高水准的性格演员。如果你随便放一部你很久没看过的心仪电影，你可能会想，哦，他在这儿呢。斯蒂芬·格雷厄姆在那儿呢，对。另一个很好的例子，我们最近刚聊过，
of somebody who had talent, came from, didn't come from an environment that was conducive to making his way into Shobas, and had a mentor, had somebody who said, hey, this kid's great, he should go here, and just another, you know. Yeah, we've talked about before,
一个极具才华的人，出身并不是那种有利于进入演艺圈的环境，但他遇到了一个导师，一个对他说“嘿，这孩子很棒，他应该去这儿”的人，这又是一个……对，我们以前聊过，
you need that next stage of people that believe in you after your parents. Yeah, we've talked about before, you need that next stage of people that believe in you after your parents. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm still looking. Oh, I know. Listen, I believe in you. Sean, look at me. I'm looking at you.
除了父母之外，你需要人生中下一阶段那些相信你的人。对，我们以前聊过，除了父母之外，你需要人生中下一阶段那些相信你的人。对，对，对。我还在找呢。哦，我懂。听着，我相信你。肖恩，看着我。我在看着你。
Hey, you're great. Oh no, your eyes are crossing. Your eyes are crossing. I'm trying to find you, I'm trying to find you. So, Jason and Will, I had, I ordered, I'm trying to find you. I'm trying to find you so Jason and Will I had I ordered remember when I told you I was in Ohio Oh my god, you know what the worst part is? It's just the fucking It's his face
嘿，你很棒。哦不，你的斗鸡眼了。你的斗鸡眼了。我想找到你，我想找到你。所以，杰森和威尔，我有……我订了……我想找到你。我想找到你，所以杰森和威尔，我有……我订了……还记得我跟你说过我在俄亥俄州吗？哦天哪，你知道最糟糕的部分是什么吗？就是他妈的……就是他的脸。
So I'd love to watch you change lanes on the highway. You must put your car into a four-wheel slide when you do it. I love I'm still laughing at, so fairy kicks, listen. So, no, I really did order some, when I was in Ohio last weekend, I ordered some tea and it was hibiscus tea. Yeah, okay. So the opposite of hibiscus tea would probably be chamomile. Are you trying to get us to say bye, hibiscus tea would probably be. Chamomile?
所以我很想看你在高速公路上变道。你变道时一定得让车来个四轮侧滑吧。我喜欢……我还在笑刚才那个“仙女蛋糕”，听着。所以，不，我真的订了一些，上周末我在俄亥俄州的时候，我订了一些茶，是木槿花茶（hibiscus tea）。好吧，好吧。那么木槿花茶的反义词大概就是洋甘菊茶（chamomile）了吧。你是想让我们说再见吗，木槿花茶大概是……洋甘菊？
Are you trying to get us to say bye, hibiscus? Yeah. Well, that's not a thing. That's not a word. Well, we do that sometimes where it's not the thing. No, no, sorry, Jay. I deciphered that. I mean, we almost needed the Enigma machine for that.
你是想让我们说再见吗，木槿花？对。好吧，根本没这说法。这不是个词。好吧，我们有时会说这种没这说法的词。不，不，抱歉，杰伊。我破译出来了。我的意思是，我们为了这个几乎需要一台恩尼格玛密码机了。
I was nowhere near. I can't believe you got that. I was nowhere near that. Hibis you got that. I was nowhere near that. Hi, Biscous. Okay, let me do another one. We know what we just planted in the backyard. Did you see him click the file? This is what you do during the day.
我差得十万八千里。真不敢相信你居然猜出来了。我离那个答案十万八千里呢。木槿花，你居然猜出来了。我离那答案十万八千里呢。木槿花，好吧，我再来一个。你知道我们在后院种了什么吗？你看到他点文件了吗？这就是你白天在做的事。
I was in the backyard and we planted some hydrangeas. Okay. And so after we were done and I walked away, I said, bye, hydrangeas. That one's not bad. Jesus Christ. Sorry, listener. We'll see you next time.
我在后院，我们种了一些绣球花（hydrangeas）。好吧。等我们弄完走开后，我说：“拜拜，绣球花。”这个还行。天呐。抱歉，听众朋友们。我们下期见。
Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smartless is 100% organic Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
聪明。绝顶。聪明绝顶（SmartLess）是100%纯天然的聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。聪明。绝顶。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。